[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right all right all right testing
testing one two round what it do sunday
the lord's day we are back
feeling better a little better let me
know how my levels are sounding hustle
what's going on brother appreciate you
let me know what i'm doing out here big
cloud i see you but i gotta get you back
in the realms with a minute what's going
on christopher jones general mac making
sure everybody's respectful you know
that's how we keep it we got to keep it
respectful it is what it is phantom
knife tsws gaming what's going on thank
you i appreciate you brother yeah man
definitely under the weather this week
feeling better hustle what's up bro
what's going on man
trying to get some uh
better care and rest i got to do better
about it i'm killing myself a little bit
senpai what's going on chillin chillin
yeah we got a big one we got a big one
you know what i mean we have
literally resolution games in the
building
get to talk to them see what's going on
with them we got great topics lined up
addicts in the building
i had to talk to the people right quick
what's going on guys no doubt mister the
lord of hammers
[Laughter]
you know the reference if you watch the
stream talk to him
[Music]
i've been watching y'all i've been
watching y'all
double tj what's going on now i'm omar
my guy
addicted coming in a little bit low
hustle
on the check in
you know what i'm saying
levels coming in low make sure
everything's good working out the kinks
yeah you're not you know you're hitting
yelling at you you're definitely a
little lower he's right baby okay oh
yeah
yeah yeah yeah you got you guys
[Music]
no it's here but for some reason like
it's they're acting like it's on another
screen but oh doesn't exist or some
double screen
technical difficulties gotta love it
what's going on people so yeah we will
get gust off step mark in the building
he'll be pulling up black conflict x
what's going on oh dj what's going on
hey guys long time
i love what he does hey guys long time
listen like
you know what i'm saying absolute salute
let's take care of that right quick
yeah akw attic is way low
all right he working on it we appreciate
it phantom knife what's going on
what is going on
anyway so we
we like we like like that fox rally game
what's going on fine brother what is
going on i see you out in them from
twitter streets very passionate some
stuff was brought to my attention all
right how do i sound wild way too crazy
way too crazy
i'm still louder than you but at least
you're hitting the yellow
give me my one more my chat
hello i think when you just talk louder
it'll be better you're just talking
really lonely
but anyway look y'all a lot of show
fans like clippy clippings yeah i know
you podcast hosting 101 you know how
this is
betrayed what's going on salute so yeah
we gonna get gust off of the building
the king will be pulling up sauv may not
make it today because um solve is
definitely
working some stuff went down so he might
not be able to make it today but um yeah
we got a big show planned out still so
much surprises and some great topics
we're going to talk about it and i will
see y'all
[Music]
so
my
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making
[Music]
for them to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we were messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on the song with me that's
understandable i kill a beat and they
want to compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all so dramatical i know it's random
but i'm addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting the reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
um
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled put them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell an uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and had this be swearing they
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
check my
[Music]
dog thing very loyal but i ain't gonna
hold you i ain't here to boy you you
ain't gotta say it i'm embarrassed for
you i always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
an uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that
again here you hear you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started i am
well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lord's podcast right now
as we speak and uh i guess i'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to started regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they're really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say i'm better
than money because you can bank on me
being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vote on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
um
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
i'ma just chill and watch so many snacks
in the attic i wanted to chill with the
pack and be like a young wolf but then
they would mistake me for addict if i
can imagine it's cool to give you some
advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't give her
that option you're gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty ain't not a pretender
detrimental to an elemental what's the
avatar to a knee bender i gotta be meto
i know it's my destiny work the cognito
who cares if you fly if you steal a
mosquito you swear you ain't something
but really be stevo
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news even if you
really was that jew king david still be
the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible was it in nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this
[Music]
are testing mic check do a little quick
check real quick at it just make sure
yup i see levels there we go i see love
i always get excited when i see levels
all right
and we are live here you hear you and
welcome to the iron lords podcast llc
and also live on lords of gaming.net
episode number 246 and it's a glorious
sunday we're back at the round table on
the lord's day i'm extremely excited
about our special guest and we've got
dmeo and resolution games
elden ring impressions
witch queen impressions fallout new
vegas 2 and game pass to steam deck to
discuss so we're going to get right into
it
i want to introduce a lord who is not
only developed into one of the most
highly addictive and innovative vr
titles in 2021 but whose studio has
truly transcended on what a tabletop
turn-based dungeon crawling cooperative
rpg can aspire to be
introducing the producer at resolution
games and the critically acclaimed demo
vr and pc edition franchise
the lord of guardians hunters bards
assassins and sorcerers whose player
base always meets at our favorite 80s
steve's heroes hangout
live from stockholm sweden and kind
enough to make his debut into the realm
of the lords
my man lord gustav denmark of resolution
games how we doing sir
you're a db oh lord man first of all
your lord of your realm
truly respect what you guys do first of
all how are you doing and uh what have
you been up to what games have you been
playing man
so most recently uh
i yeah started the horizon forbidden
west
but i only came through the intro and
then i had to do other stuff so
too early to give like impressions on
that
you started at the horizon no question
the question i'm i'm also assuming a lot
of demo or we're taking a little break
from the emails you dropped a lot of
stuff this week
yeah exactly we we uh
made our steam next first debut with the
2d version
producing now and also the heroes
hangout yes yes yes yes they're asking
me to turn you up just a little bit more
they they want to hear your volume level
a little bit more good stuff they're
excited they're excited but good to have
you in the realm you already know salute
we have a big show and of course we got
the four horsemen of gaming but uh we
may be down one horseman send some love
out to solve some has to work today you
know i'm saying definitely wanted to be
here uh hopefully maybe it could sneak
in but i doubt that they got to work
but it is what it is and you already
know we still got the other three
horsemen gaming my co-host with the
colemos my brother from another mother
the difficult game conqueror lord of his
own world and the how of the young wolf
my man lord addict of the attic show how
we doing sir
doing pretty good man uh yeah i ended up
grinding way too long on destiny last
night
like there is like this really crazy
cheese going on right now
and it's just like it's addicting like
i kind of get the same feeling when i
play like a final fantasy game and i'm
grinding to kill like that that in-game
boss it's just like every time i get a
chest i'm like what's the next one gonna
happen
it was ridiculous but you know it's it's
been a good uh it's been a good week man
we i just want to take a moment and
appreciate
how good game he's been in the past
month yes like it is
it is
ridiculous like i don't i can't name
a month
in a long long long time maybe if ever
with this many solid franchises and
games that came out in a matter of 30
days we
got to say that your gaming life is
really shorter oh lord
i i do have better days but
for your days it's beautiful
do your favorite cake turn your levels
up just a little bit too as well kill it
a little low but um no you're good
you're good now um again solved out here
so i know the chat is on us they said no
soft the super chats are about to be
chaos listen we're not as good as solve
but we're going to do our best you could
get to give me a check give me a check
oh yeah there we go there we go that's
the keg i know that we go what's going
on so you already know i get a song i
mean you want to get a couple cause
they're flying in i just want to make
sure we're on point actually i get two
so we got uh my man
okay dude two dozen chat welcome back
king happy sunday lords no doubt what's
up no doubt necromancer zeo find out
super chat hey lords welcome back king
how about that witch queen speaking of
which and of course we have the
incredible hulk of this aka the access
gamer who the prophet of xbox swamy king
of the statues who demands nothing less
than that premium experience it is the
leader of the fraud alert movement
b
love it lord king how we doing sir
better than chris colbert oh
shout out to top ranked boxing last
night this is when calling out people
goes wrong listen a lot of great
fighters um and i'm talking about chris
colbert here a lot and you guys might
not know him but you know climbing the
ranks and stuff like that uh great
fighters don't disparage their peers
they acknowledge their peers and they
continue to you know have that tunnel
vision to greatness uh the moment you
decide to disparage your peers uh
humbling will be in your cards so um he
got humbled because he was overlooking
his competition in front of him tunnel
vision means you don't look past anyone
you look straight forward and you go
through your opponents to get to the top
so
chris colbert hopefully you learn from
this and hopefully you can come back
all right dominican republic what's
going on happy independence day
local coma style my people across
america my extended family um let me
tell you guys i know it's a wonderful
day celebrate uh greatly remember
tomorrow's monday so you gotta go to
work
don't get too crazy don't get too okay
don't get too crazy
get crazy
um
what uh what i've been playing
so
i got i got to give attic his bars here
i got to give him his flowers he's
definitely been
this guy i don't know how he does it but
attic has been grinding and he's been
playing and he's been i've been watching
his channel um i have to say i wasn't
going to get elden ring and oh because
of attic i gotta get it oh
i sat there and watched him uh play
elden ring yes
and
i'm going to tell you if you guys aren't
watching addict yeah like one of the
best shoes
very underrated streamer right and he's
able to do things the way he's able to
multitask he's reading the chat while
he's playing and he's doing difficult
yes i really got to respect that because
i'm doing one or the other
so i'm not reading the chat and i'm not
saying are we not talking to you
i'm focusing on this life in depth
situation
people was uh they was in the chat
and they're like because i was literally
like
while he's moving
like
telling them what he's going to do yes
and reading the chat they're like how
are you doing that it's like once like
when you play these from software games
enough like i've played like
you know what they're gonna do before
they're gonna do and like i've always
been good at reading patterns in general
with anything and it's just like okay
now he's about to do these two these two
daggers he's like he might because
sometimes like they design their games
where
their patterns sometimes changes
depending on what you do
so you know that's the only thing but
i will say you know we'll get to eldon
ring but it's it's been a good
experience good
i i want that game now
i i definitely do um i've been playing
plato's witch queen
i i and we're gonna get to we'll get to
we got a topic
but let me tell you man first i gotta
give a shout out to the liz and i got to
give a shout out to drunken um oh clan
mates iop clan stand up right yes i'll
be clan stand up big clan is probably
the best clan on that's the show for
sure you call out
and people join in and they they play i
want to tell you guys
i'm accessible if you have my game
attack you see me on i'm in a party i
talk a little bit different um
a lot of iop after
same time i'm accessible join in have
fun we're all gamers i'm available so
you know you see me on um i'm not bougie
come on in we have fun
i'm the exact opposite of everything he
said
uh i don't want 80 people in the park
in the party
if it's more than three i feel
claustrophobic
so so for addicts rule of engagements
they need to send you a message message
to permission yeah no no no you if
here's the thing like it's not that it
gives people it's just like i don't
really like i like my friends list of
people like that i know that's gonna
play games with me yeah so nine times
out of ten i'm not following people back
on xbox because i did i had that really
bad issue
on uh what's that called um on just lfg
in general okay well i'll keep adding
people because i played a game with them
and then six seven months later you come
back who is this you don't even remember
what it is and then i gotta delete them
so i don't i don't [ __ ] wait why are
they gonna get deleted
because i i had people on xbox to play
xbox games if i don't play xbox with you
or at least talk to you in a party
you're up out of there i'm sorry like
ridiculous we gotta get you let me get a
couple super chats because i get it i'll
get crazy gave it out gaming shout out
member for five months salute put the
crest up pokemon scarlet and violet
announced today no doubt you know i need
to watch a youtube video on that yes
how why is that sitting announcing stuff
on a sunday take a break nintendo
nintendo's excited percolator nine
thousand follow super chat hello lords
just please accept my dues don't smite
me please i am i am not worthy i have a
great day lord salute shroom kingdom two
dollar super chats
[Music]
in the building
yeah i i that's why i took these as i
because i'm trying to
i feel like people
people like my mispronounces yes these
days now i agree oh shout out to
platinum j two dollars
okay dominica no doubt mexican zoidberg
member for 15 months okay cool all right
so let me uh introduce myself the gaming
ninja the [ __ ] nobody lord cognito
spraying that realm in the realistic
aroma iop not telling what you want to
hear but what you need to hear shout out
to definitely do shout out to mr maddie
plays had a great episode kind of
talking more about the uh activision
call of duty stuff um some more
intricacies there also a funny segment
king you'll laugh what game you would
actually drop it
like it's hot for and now oh my god yeah
it was fun you had to pick one game
and it was hilarious um yeah i think i
got to watch it you got to watch it you
got to watch it it's absolutely i also
got to say one thing
um
30 days of coach is still in effect oh
make sure that you're gonna make uh uh
spaces about that
thank you shout out to the spaces people
don't know shout out to hustle and
motivate member 56 a couple of black
eyes after playing ellen ring definitely
a good time thanks for the help addict
no doubt and uh yeah again for me it's
been that also check out all of the
patreon we got an exclusive update for
sea of thieves shout out to ben smith um
last word what he bought this time
travis is up all right now on iop chat
we had paul tassie from forbes up
earlier that was amazing everything
which queen impressions
yeah spoiler cast spoiler cast what's
that
did you read that are the ones by
mexicans over um no um
king actually wants to play a game
that's not on game pass hallelujah
praise the lord hello
and you know what happened i'ma buy this
game and phil dominus maximus really is
going to make it available in game pass
and i'm going to come straight from you
zory boy
thank you gabe and alex thank you you
already know and yeah it's been that as
far as b game wise uh obviously
destiny's been fun to grind doing the
witch queen getting all that we'll get
into that later and of course
dbo which we will get into last night
yeah we're gonna have a nice run shout
out to it shout out to kai bachchu shout
out the volacon shout
tv had a good run met up in the hangout
but we go we got stuff to talk about
yeah we're gonna talk about that we're
gonna get it
what's up uh someone said you missed the
super chat did you you got you
tried
oh okay okay okay yeah i think you got
it but um just read it just in case just
in case you're busy then we'll start uh
so
juvie said uh welcome back uh king yeah
i got that i gotta go
no doubt so look let's get into it you
already know what we're here for so now
we got into what the lords have been
playing we gotta focus on local stuff
his video game system history his
journey at being a producer at
resolution games and of course what led
him to working on one of the most
addicting and rising in popularity games
of demio so uh local stuff man let's
start a little bit for the beginning
let's get a brief kind of your video
game system history and kind of what
kind of games got you into gaming
yeah so uh for me it's always been i've
always been a nintendo kid right
so i started off with a nes system the
8-bit
nintendo machine i remember
i was saving up for that and one day my
dad
when i bought it for me that was really
awesome and then like nice super
nintendo and the nintendo 64.
uh recently i've been playing a lot on
my switch
what you've been playing on sweatshirt
so mostly stardew valley i'm a sucker
for those like community same games yes
yes yes yes
moon on the gameboy and nice
no i gotta ask you this because you
jumped in the room with a lot of sega
kids in here so i have to ask you during
the nintendo era the 8-bit 16-bit all
that stuff were you ever tempted by sega
now so i had a friend he had a master
system right so good friends
to get some variation going but i always
get coming back nintendo okay i just
want to point out that every time we
talk about someone with sega it's always
i had a friend uh the neighbor had one
he's like are you implying something
no i'm not implying i'm stating fat
i just want to know right um how was
sega marketed over there good question
because i know nintendo market globally
right they marketed my neighbors got one
you should plum play it that's how they
marketed it so it's a bit like coke
versus pepsi right okay okay
uh
is pepsi max okay
that's the question you get right right
that was the thing with sega like it was
always the second rate at least
i'm not sure if it was marketing or just
like my my friends i was hanging out
with
uh so but nintendo was the thing to have
no it's fair fair enough and um just as
far as you know accessibility and stuff
like that you know i guess that's our
question because in the states it was
kind of different so i'm glad king did
ask that you know because of what else
what i've noticed is um anytime we have
uh people from europe uh
what happens is i don't think sega was
marketed properly in europe and i think
nintendo saw that gap and actually
really blanket marketed europe and they
got a foothold there and it became like
the number one choice like you said like
pepsi versus coke like you know pepsi
max or whatever so it's i always think
it's usually whoever gets the foothold
in the region actually has a leg up when
it comes to marketing and shelf space so
shelf space probably nintendo was
actually first nintendo was uh i mean
and sega was to the side so when you
came in as a kid you know you see
nintendo and then everybody else that
you know basically has it except for
that one kid you're your friend
yeah salud we love love to hear it so we
go move forward cause we gotta take
advantage of the time we have with you
about being a producer at uh resolution
games not just into demo just yet but i
wanna talk about like
how did that journey start to become a
producer and getting into a developer
making video games and then also why the
passion for vr games specifically at a
studio at resolution games
yeah so uh
in terms of becoming a producer
i studied the computer science at
university and then like my my uh
specialization was in like i think it
was called the sign of interactive
systems okay okay so i guess that's a
good
we like that background so
but when i started in games i was
actually
a programmer oh nice work as a
developer for like
three or four years but the thing with
like the game industry right is
it tends to attract the best coders and
i was not one of them so
i had shopping skills against chopping
up the tools in the industry
he said he found out very quickly
[Laughter]
this boy who had that sega he was really
good
i give you credit i mean program is it's
not it's not easy we'll continue
continuing
yeah no but so uh
and then i was working with like uh
mobile games and
web-based games and i was really early
on on like facebook games oh okay so i
must have been doing my career in the
casual realm
okay okay all right so let me ask you a
question um
when
when you go to develop a game uh for
casual bass
uh opposed to a hardcore bass what do
you find to be a little bit easier do
you find it because you know like
hardcore has their little niche and
stuff that you have to hit right and the
casual base also you have to make it
accessible in the manner of
how broad it is what do you find to be a
little bit easier in uh working with the
casual base or working for the hardcore
base
that's a great question
so i mean no one can fool anyone right a
great game is a great game so uh
i guess when it comes to like hardcore
games that's a lot of around like
building up the lore and uh yeah
stuff that people can really geek out on
right
but
again i worked at king yeah he worked he
worked at king king
yes yeah which is recently acquired by
uh by microsoft or
hopefully soon to be maybe depending on
the regulations
yes continue
now so um
uh over i think that's actually like a
casual packaging for a game that's
really hardcore you think about it right
people spend a lot of time in that game
right and it becomes
really hard i mean of course it's not
hardcore like from software right
yeah yeah i don't know
it's uh it has a dedicated uh
audience right
fair enough enough and then just there
now that you know studio coach obviously
you have that
mobile background you've been doing that
you know you get to resolution games and
then now what i notice is like you guys
are one of the you know premiere up and
coming
ar vr you know kind of studios and it's
like i guess my question is from
culturally as a studio you know
what makes a studio say hey because
let's be real like the ar vr market is
not like huge it's still it's slightly
growing but my question is what makes
people say you know what we're gonna
take a crack at this and try to make
quality games in that you know that kind
of environment because that's a huge
risk
yeah yeah it is
no we saw an opportunity so i guess uh
uh i joined resolution very early like i
was the uh
actually the second employee i started
on the same day as the first employee
but he signed papers the day before me
so wow
so he get the credit but you was there
with the brick they put the first brick
down you was there okay that's what i
want yeah
he's like no i i mean literal brick he's
building this adam you see how you
he was like i was technically first it's
just the other guy signing the paper
[Laughter]
salute
continue
that's how i'm going to start wording
every time iops mentioned i was there
when the bricks were put up oh no you
always mentioned it to me you'd be like
no i i was the one that said the name i
had
yeah you you went back to an old
facebook message i'm like damn we got
the receipts
you know he said they got fights over it
so they'd probably be inside the break
room
like number one producers here no no no
you gotta love it you gotta load it in
fight so continue number two so continue
you're there you're there at the very
very beginning you jump on board so like
what was this the shift that that i mean
what was the mindset at that time we're
gonna we're gonna tackle arvr from the
beginning was it mobile in the beginning
i know you guys got like angry birds you
got a whole bunch of different titles
that we get into exactly tell me about
the mindset of what you got to create in
vr in general
so the early early days of vr was or
we're still in the early days of vr you
could say yeah
but uh it was those were you those uh
you had this headset where you put your
smartphone in yeah
the link was very short yeah
so we actually focused on that early on
like oculus had the uh
the rift or the dk2 i think was called
like the development kit yeah that was
the only thing in our south and then the
htc vine
[Music]
so we we decided to focus on mobile
games early on
or mobile vr games i would say
and i had this game
called
it ended up being bait it's a very
casual fishing adventure okay
that i've been working on for a long
time even before resolution started and
then our ceo tommy uh him and i we know
each other we've been working together
for 20 years oh salute
so he called me and said
asked if i wanted to come and produce
that fishing game okay
our mission was to build like
approachable or casual uh vr games
because the only was there right
at that point was
like
really jarring
roller coaster rides
yeah jump scare games and space shooters
so that's where we started off and then
i think
as a company we evolved beyond that
this super casual because the audience
is not really there and yeah i guess
demio is definitely like yeah ah so we
can speak
all right speaking speaking of which
perfect transition
look you know this debate event you know
it's the reason why a lot of us are here
is this game i'm i'm done talking we
gotta show the people as uh solvers say
we use the old one
rickroot quote from wwe hit the music
descending into the dark dungeons of
forgotten memories
[Music]
the mighty guardian found himself called
an old but familiar magic
whispering a call to adventure
compelled by fate he summoned the old
fellowship
all right boys what's the plan of attack
here you gotta get the key and then we
gotta go to the exit
all right i'm gonna try to take out this
little spider looking thing do it john
[Music]
do i need to save you there's a car you
got a
okay hang on i got this
[Music]
what about this door over here i have a
feeling this could get ugly
they're killing you man you're taking a
beating i'm about to die
[Music]
let's do this
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
all right you got that devio right now
again currently vr oculus quest steamvr
and also pc edition the demo is out
right now so go check that out for my pc
steam users but this is the main event
y'all this is why we're here this is the
game everyone is raving about that can
that game get played in 2d as well yes
yes yeah why
he said pc i don't know he said pc but
he didn't explain the pancake people oh
my lord pancake now we do it flat after
flight of 30. get it okay you know
as long as the strawberry pancakes we're
fine ridiculous you can put blueberries
in it you're still a pancake
time on pancake talk is it at least good
pancake time or pancake time delicious
back to the main event dvo y'all this is
it we're here so um gotta ask gustav man
i mean this thing is really taking
everybody by storm you know and um i
wanted to ask you just kind of like
brainstorming the idea of the creation
of demio because basically this thing is
like you know this amazing you got the
cooperative you got the dungeons and
jack dragons it's like dungeon dragon
meet xcom meets tabletop diablo it's
just it's so much going on and then with
the vr portrait i know we're gonna get
into our pc and the steam edition that
just came demo just came out but what's
really cool is like the interactions the
vr manipulation like picking up a piece
putting it you know what i'm saying over
doing that stuff and and manipulating
this thing it's just so cool so i gotta
ask you
like august did in development
did the team know
you guys had a hit on your hand with
demio
yeah i think we knew early on right
it's uh when you
have those like
uh
when you guys are end up playing more
than you're developing okay maybe we
need to stop
when you can't stop when you keep like
yeah
you
want to get back into it yeah you know
you're onto something right and
especially for vr because there is a bit
of a
a bit of a hurdle to put on the headset
right yes
so
it's that's one of the tricky parts with
building vr games is to make people like
long to get back into it yes i think
we actually managed to to get that with
the withdemio like we nailed it oh
for sure i mean you know what i know we
know you guys nailed it
when
all of the people i play with are now
talking about extended batteries
for their oculus quest
excuse me better questions like what
everyone's asking like yo it's king it's
so bad now like i know that people who
don't have extended batteries on their
on their vr headsets what's their plug
they're buying a a pack like an exp a
pack and connecting it a battery pack a
portable one i had to do that yeah you
remember listen let me tell you and
i understand about the hurdles that you
talked about with the um putting on the
vr right um because you can have it
there
but there's also a hurdle to it now my
thing is was the oculus two or the meta
two
um
like well i guess uh
no no you got a medic better question
why is that uh um a boon because
no wires
gives it a a a feeling of freedom
right and then you know you set up your
little barrier it's a lot of so you
could play it anywhere actually you know
sometimes i'm in a four year playing it
by myself you know that's away from
other people so you don't have to have
that fear of punching the tv breaking
into your tv or your monitors or
anything um was did you see like a spike
uh once that was accessible over this
holiday season because i've noticed i've
never seen this much vr being purchased
and in the twitter space with the
friends that i do have uh did you see
like a huge spike in and your
recommendation for your game because
your game is really like on the first
front page of of the oculus page
now we've seen this christmas was great
for sales and i think it's across the
board so
i think uh
uh
oculus or mata i guess meta oculus
managed to sell a lot of questions this
i literally consider demio
like an oculus seller like yeah you're
not buying that game for oculus like
what are you doing just take it back
like
so there is a slight obstacle right
right putting the headset on but once
you're in
i think uh like the the immersion you
get from oh yeah
so um the team or what are are you guys
huge um board game players because
cog and i used to play strategic goals
and stuff like that downstairs in the
house so you know clue and stuff so
we're huge board players right as far as
video games go that's nice but sometimes
you want to detach yourself from the
technology of it and you just want to
sit there and play a board game move
your pieces used to play battleship and
stuff like that a lot so
you gave me the first this is the first
time
i got the feeling of having a board game
with this technology
i was able to pick up my little i for a
while i i know i was geeking out i know
they was laughing at me and i really
didn't care um i was zooming in so close
when you do the zoom and you pull out
and then you get up close i didn't even
know i know the demo kind of teaches
that but i know how close you can get up
to it and you see the detailing
characters continue
yeah like
you guys really
kneeled
that feeling because you know when you
get your your little men inside the box
right and you take them out and you look
at them and you can do this with your
hand and manipulate it and get as close
as you want to get you guys got that
actual feeling down pack of manipulating
your character looking at them picking
them up turn them around and you did it
with cards too when the cards pop up
that
that stuff goes
deep into
looking at how board games is revered
yeah translating that over into the
technology and i want to know how the
hell did you guys transfer that over
what was that process like
yeah so it was a
quite a long process like we work
together with the uh mike booth if you
know him
he's actually the game uh
game director for
email and we do like weekly play tests
and i know that him and uh
and tommy or ceo they were talking a lot
about like how can we turn like
building a casual rpg pretty much or not
casual but like um
not the pen and paper rpg right
like uh
like something turn-based and very like
physical and like you grab stuff and
your old dice and you play cards
uh and
we uh
we worked for for a few years on this
title actually and it's it's been
designed
designed like inside out oh wow inside
vr around the table like all those rules
and uh yeah so so how how long the
interactions and stuff i'm sorry it's
all been played testing yeah so i was
just gonna ask like you guys had the
vision and shout out to a lot of people
say yo they love if you love dmd you're
gonna love this game i'm telling you
this is like the spirit of dnd
especially when you're playing and you
see the background it's like an 80s
background you're in someone's basement
it's the vibe it's an energy but my
question to to to expound what you were
saying like you know you guys had that
vid like how long was it in development
this idea like how long were you sitting
on the idea before it kind of came into
fruition
yeah that's a good question actually so
i i joined demio fairly recently i've
been focusing on other social vr games
at resolution before so i just did the
cookout if you guys have tried that
which is
four player co-op around the table as
well but it's more like
overcooked action yeah
stuff right yeah
laid back earlier but i think it was in
development for at least two years wow
wow okay okay yeah
it's pretty yeah we have to try to cook
out for sure um the basement reminds me
of stranger things right if anybody ever
watched stranger things see it's it's
they hit a lot of hall marks
and that's what i'm trying to say like
if you're in in the now the game is in
the now right and if you uh watch
stranger things remember they were in
the basement playing d and d
yeah if you play the game and you look
around
you're like wow the basement looks like
and feels like a stranger things the
music is amazing
dnd
so it gives you this 80s feel yes
with the technology but still playing in
a board game and i've i've i've played
a lot
of vr i was the vr you're the early
adopter before everybody else wanted to
play vr
i'm going to tell you
i have not played a game that is um this
addicting yes
in a vr space that the battery runs out
and they they know i was like oh my god
my battery's running out and i had to
have i had a supplicant battery on the
side and i had to plug it into my
headset and you know shout out to cog i
went and got the extended battery for it
but um
this level of addiction to this game
this wanting to get back to the game and
i believe that comes from all the
hallmarks that you did hit uh all the
position periods what what what period
of time did you guys think about when
y'all went into development i know you
said you came in later on but uh do you
know what period of time that they were
shooting for like late 90s early 80s
yeah i would i would say late 80s early
90s maybe nice okay right or or maybe
even a bit
earlier than that like it's uh mm-hmm
strangest thing i don't remember when
stranger king things came out initially
but
like it was of course like uh yeah
it has been up for discussion
oh
yeah oh inspiration of course right nice
yeah
nice
trying to capture that feeling right
there
yeah
out of curiosity
i know we're going to talk about the pc
version of dmeo but was that like an
afterthought after the success of demio
or was that something that was always on
the on on the roadmap eventually was to
bring it to more platforms
it was uh on the uh like from from the
get-go
as soon as we realized like this this is
gonna be a great game now we just have
to execute and
we started building the pc version early
but then we we instead focused on
getting the vr game out right
and then
the pc
version has been
in development
again since like after summer or
something okay
okay yeah i got all more questions for
you now you know again we talk about you
know how fun it is how great it is and
stuff like that i definitely want to ask
you about the challenges you know that
the team faced and again i know you came
on right right around roots of evil i
think right you came on around that time
as far as emails are concerned but um a
few months earlier oh before okay so
before rules okay great you know and
then you know prior to roots of evil
again they're like literally adventures
it reminds me the old tabletop king i
love it you have what is it the black
sarcophagus and was it the the rat king
and then roots of evil which is the the
fourth adventure now but my question as
far as the challenges obviously we talk
about this virtual reality is tabletop
rpg you got random generated you know uh
enemies you got the card system where
you kind of look at your wrist and you
see the cards and going on got balance
and all these intrinsic abilities with
the characters so
what do you think were some of the the
challenges kind of getting the game made
or feature wise that you know may have
been issues just with the development i
know one was cloud saves at one point
i'm glad you kind of got that straight
now but any any challenges that you guys
experience along the way
yeah so i mean it's it's complex
products right it's a four-player
co-op like the the network code have to
work and everything needs to be synced
uh
if you look at something and point at it
and say oh look at this thing
the others better know what you're
pointing at like the
same thing right as soon as you uh so
that's that's one of the more um
like technical challenges
i would say and then i think
one challenge that's also a very fun
thing is the whole like as we add new
mechanics
new enemies um
we get this like unexpected behaviors
right
something we developed like months or
even years ago suddenly have to to work
together with a new mechanic and how how
will that work
like
exploring that is a big part of this
type of game right so really take care
in like adding
and you know i want to take for that
perspective that you just said because i
do think sometimes that you know
especially us as gamers we try to act
like we know more than the actual
developers and like look look at look at
like
mechanics like in destiny with like
stasis
where it was so bad it was breaking
other
features of games like imagine like how
crazy it would be that it's like you
think you're good on something and then
a couple years later you're like now i
gotta go recode like parts of the
original game because there's some new
stuff i'm adding like
it's crazy how stuff like that happens
because that's not the first time we've
heard about stuff like that like we're
constantly hearing about like backwards
compatibility where you know old code or
preventing new features from happening
with that game and so it it it is
interesting that you know stuff like
that happens even on a software base
yeah yeah i got a question okay
i got a question since we're talking
about breaking stuff
right um
vr
to pancake oh god
right
now
i know me
we we're in seeing the world
uh you're able to turn around and look
at stuff in the pancake uh are you guys
uh
making the world uh able to be like
manipulated so you can actually see
around
and and stuff like that
you're giving the 2d experience with uh
like a 4d type of play to it or or
um because
what's the thought process in going into
that because i know it has to be
monumental because coming from that 4d
3d space
uh you know the oculus space
to actually get that to a 2d visual
um i know it must be challenging because
i don't know because i don't i don't
develop games so uh how challenging was
it and um what's the process like
so i would say like building a pancake
version of a vr game
stop saying okay
don't get in trouble listen
don't get in trouble saying king saves
those are my words don't worry about it
yes yes we got to protect us there's a
conversation between me and him actually
we didn't know what to call it like what
is it is it desktop is it what is it so
we actually called it pancakes
shout out the king shout out the king he
actually okay i stand corrected
no but it's like
people are putting pancake emojis in the
chat yeah they're putting pancake emojis
in the chat they're ridiculous continue
because though
yeah no but it's it's uh
it's mostly a matter of
like it's a ux design challenge to take
something from vr into 2d right right
right
when designing uh vr games
one of the
i think where
where you can really make or break a
game or at least
very much add a new dimension to a game
it's the way you interact with the game
right because since also the
oculus like the quest yeah you have your
your
your six degrees of freedom of your head
and two hands right so you can actually
interact as you would
with the the normal world you can like
type a keyboard or whatever in in the
virtual world
and
then when you remove that dimension uh
in designing for for for 2d or for
pancakes
something gets lost of course but on the
other like there's so many more um
conventions to look at right so there's
not that many vr games so for a lot of
the time we have to like invent the
wheel
again right for a specific uh
interaction we need to figure out how to
do that right because no one has done it
before in the game
uh it was more true like when we started
with a solution than it is today because
now there's a lot of games and they're
starting to like emerge this uh like um
ways to do things right right uh but a
lot of stuff has been tested like you
push your finger through a button to to
punch it or do you have those little
lasers shooting out the point right yeah
yeah you got you got that's what i like
about it you guys give the option you
you can do the physical i'm picking up
my piece i'm moving it but you can also
point and say hey i'm going to grab it
and do it that way continue right yeah
so you you did a cog way and you did it
my way because i don't pick up the stuff
[Laughter]
so i think that's uh
uh
like of course you can rotate you can
zoom in really close in the 2d version
as well oh okay good cool yeah that was
my biggest you know question to it
because like if
my battery's not running out
we also added one thing so when playing
i don't think it's tutorialized yet so
you can't really find out uh it's a bit
of a hidden feature but
when playing the the pc uh
version now if you press and hold the c
button
okay
and end up inside your home at the side
of the table so you can get like an eye
contact with your video
yes i didn't know that that's huge
that's huge
yeah because they look like quarter-hour
people
and i love that i love that i'm glad you
mentioned that because we did mention
that also about demon which is like
again with the vr aspect and now you're
also saying in the in the the pc aspect
one of the coolest thing is you're
actually seeing the hand and your people
that you're playing with interact around
the board so it gives you that illusion
that feel like yo i'm with my friends
physically in a room doing it
can i voice like a little bit of
critique when it comes to that like it i
don't know how hard it would be would it
be like difficult to like disable that
if you don't want to see it because
sometimes like the heads be getting in
front of you but they get in your way
like move no
get your hand out my face like some
people would enjoy the ability to turn
that off if they don't want it because
sometimes it do be mad at all so the
hand will be in in front of me i'm like
i can't can you do you mind
i i might be one of those people because
i'm the guy that's like zooming up real
close getting low on the boy my face is
dead i'm trying to take good cinematic
pictures of of the battle and stuff and
i i could be one of those guys that's
interfering with addict's visual of the
book
[Music]
yes yes i'm that guy i'm that guy
is there is there thoughts of maybe uh
disabled with that fatigue
yeah i guess
definitely something we've been without
bigger fish to fry but yeah
hopefully they don't implement it and it
breaks something at it
um
did late in the game like y'all okay
y'all like uh we're about to rap and
then somebody said yo
what about acid arrows let's let's let's
get this acid arrows in it because asset
arrows would be really dope and okay so
let's put the acid arrows in we make up
the card you do all that stuff and you
put it in and it breaks up
you're gonna make a decision
all right do we go in there and fix it
for the acid arrows or do we do we just
you know uh do acid arrows in the sequel
or something like that yeah i mean i
guess there's
there's still floors it's been
it's been a bit too coming a bit too hot
before uh for our launch right yeah but
uh
we tried to to uh
to fix that right and yeah
add those things later right there's uh
there's a bunch of cards where
all we're gonna have also this card
there's cards that you're holding on to
that
just out of curiosity
whatever card you guys made and then
once you put it in there you're like
this is too much power for anyone to
hold
and i would like those cards to go to
the sorcerer please the sorcerer gang i
i i hate to i don't know if you're in
charge of balance but i'm where that i
listen everybody's got cool intrinsic
abilities the guardian is armoring up
the
attic with his assassin goes invisible
around the map goes to all the points of
interest
backstab powerful the bard is doing all
these musical cool spells and i'm
looking at the saucer like sap
don't get me wrong
zap is powerful zap zap can
definitely shut down a boss who's not
immune so that he can't attack i
understand the importance of it but it's
just like come on cause
i'm looking at everybody even though i'm
a guardian i played the source and i'm
like i feel a little jealous so jealous
i do feel like
in terms of
you know because i'm a big person on
classes like
i love how you know you you make a class
and you stick with that class and you
enhance that class but if you feel like
when i'm playing demio sometimes like
sometimes the classes don't make sense
like sometimes the transit
translations
we're gonna move past no you're good
their abilities make sense but i feel
like sometimes like their stats don't
like i don't feel like in a realm an
assassin is supposed to have the exact
same amount of health that like a tank
has in like vice versa
like a tank should do a little bit more
damage than a mage does like physically
like i feel like was there a particular
reason you guys chose to you know not
make like different stats for the
different characters was it more of a
balanced thing or was it i think it's
more of the card aspect like you guys
wanted the cards to be balanced so it
was that the reason
i think so that was actually before my
time on this project okay so i can't
really give a comprehensive answer but
uh
i mean you have to set some some
some ground rules right that you don't
change because otherwise like when when
developing games or
anything i guess
as you start nailing the rules
if you start changing stuff that you
already said like this is how it is
uh that's when you're in
in trouble right
it becomes
uh increasingly difficult to gotcha
so i get what you're saying you're
pretty much saying from your standpoint
you would say that
you know that was chosen so early into
the development cycle that it just
became part of the game by the end of it
so yeah so all i'm asking is when those
cars that y'all holding on to is some of
them powerful for the sorcerer so the
sorcerer could do because the saucers
are very jealous of bards and they're
doing their little musical tornadoes and
they're doing all these great support
i'm just joking
he's the game director right so it's
it's like the the connoisseur oh he's
the connoisseur so i'll play so it's
the dude directing the game is playing
the sorcerer he ain't fixing that if he
likes it
look we've been discussing some awesome
potential
things for for the sorcerer oh okay
i like i like potential things for the
source i i i like that i like that
terminal i like that verb bridge i like
that it could be most like like in roots
of evil right yes uh when we introduce
the water all of a sudden sap becomes
yes
powerful shame lightning thing right yes
good point good point you think about
okay okay i see what you're doing good
stuff i see what you're doing all right
we're gonna move on we're gonna move on
um i to shout out you guys out and i
think um king also mentioned that attic
mentioned it earlier like the team for
the like the music like i want to give
whoever is really in charge of the
marriage
the the who is who's the voice actress
for dbod like she's awesome like as soon
as the game starts up and the world
like the way she's talking like it gets
you in a vibe you're like so i want to
shout her out she's amazing but like in
general like who's who's in charge of
the music you guys it's phenomenal it's
a dark dungeon feel it's a mystical
elven feel like you've got it down so
salute to the team or now i just want to
know who's in charge of that because we
got to give them their flowers
yeah so that's actually my my
long-standing friend linus works with us
since uh
he was
pretty much from the beginning as well
he joined us and he's been
heading up the music and sound effects
uh
department
amazing from the title yeah
a lot of times we don't
um
see because
sometimes we don't agree on things right
but this is one game
that the consensus is that we actually
agree from the aesthetics to the music
to the game play to to to everything to
fit and i know this was
um
cogs white wheel yeah right because
he he wasn't an art uh a vr dude he
wasn't preached you know like he really
was not true
he got to vr
and you guys because he could not stop
talking about it yeah and it got to the
point where because i had uh a vive and
i had a playstation vr
and the wires and stuff just like put me
off so much that i was just like you
know what sometimes you see it there you
want to play and it's just like
i just don't want to go through the
hassle of it right just to hell with it
and then he was like yo you got to get
this oculus it's uh you know it's
wireless you know you got to try it and
i'm like i'm going to give it one last
shot type of thing and you know he got
it over to me he's like yo we're playing
demio everybody's talking playing demo
we're playing demio
and
you guys nailed it and from the
consensus of that that's how i know
uh you guys are you know destined for
great things and when he said that you
guys are going to be on this week i know
you guys was his white wheel because you
guys got him into this vr space and he's
been singing you guys praises so i just
wanted to give you guys and you the
flowers right now for turning this jaded
vr dude in the beginning
to this champion of vr and this is this
is a monumental day for us to be honest
with you to have you guys on yeah um and
to talk about this wonderful game
because this is a game we could talk
about without any fear of you know you
might not like it
trust me there's something there for
everyone and if you take the time out to
to soak it in i just wanted to say it
for anybody that's it because we have
over how many people in right now we
have over uh 300
and and some other people share this out
uh let's get this out let's let
everybody know about this game i know
sometimes vr isn't for everyone but
there is a pancake edition for you guys
on um pc out there you can definitely
check it out right now and i'm gonna
tell you they nailed the aesthetics and
i'm gonna check it out on pc myself to
see what the 2d version of it looks like
to see what it feels like to see what it
plays like if it captures that same
magic that we have in vr but i just
wanted to say that because i'm like you
guys really changed this jaded dude yeah
so
hold on i just want to say one thing and
i'll give it right back to you because
and we'll give i just want to give
continue to give him his flowers with
that because that is really true and and
the thing is for me i was i'm the guy
who's the skeptic when you were talking
about back in the day when you guys were
doing vr with the phone i remember the
samsung gear and you put like i remember
trying that and i'm going to be really
honest like i was not really impressed
with the level of technicality the
fidelity then i didn't think it was
something that was going to catch and i
know king has been on the front lines
vr vr vr i mean attica kind of the same
in that recess but we were like yes
niche hey i'm still like that you know
still on defense for certain but but
you you you guys should feel honored
because you're the only reason i turned
up
yes like literally like that's when i
knew demio hit different because
when we played it the first ball we're
like oh like for the tutorial i knew i
was like okay this is something this is
a thing this is different right and then
you play it and you're like okay co-op
strategy you got to work together you
know the fun factor and then next do you
know it's like three or four hours went
past my battery's dying and i'm like
what is going on i want to shout out
bill stillwell shout out to him from
meta as well like he was the one a lot
of people told me try demio because in
the beginning i was like all right you
know but that was the game so i
definitely to say what king said i want
you to answer this like you know
have you guys experienced where people
like hey
vr i'm new to it but because of demeo
i'm trying vr now
yeah i guess uh i've heard this before
which is good right
and i i do think demio is the first game
a lot of people play right it's easy
just give it to someone and they they
can try it out because there's no
uh
you don't get this uh the cyber seconds
right in it yeah it's very like
first game friendly and it's very like
highly interactable and you can look
around and stuff so right yeah
that that
that that's definitely true facts man
sometimes when i play
um when i play
the oculus like your game is like one of
the only games that i could play for for
over a certain amount of time without
feeling lightheaded
and that
and that's why i think i really enjoy it
so much is because like it first off
it's the type of game experience that i
enjoy
and second off like it's just like it's
one of the experiences i can have on the
oculus that just works wonders for me
and it's just been like you know calling
them they they do fine with with the
motion sickness but i've i've been
struggling with it my whole life so
like vr has always been
a very hard thing for me to do
and like the oculus 2 is like the only
one that's ever like not like benny look
complete no go like a complete no-go
and when i played devio because i i
played resident evil and
i liked it but it's just like it was it
was just a motion sickness that i just
couldn't get over but when i not demeo
resident evil but when i played demio i
was like this this is this is something
like i it was so bad because i don't
have like that extra charge and stuff
they have well i have to literally sit
as close to my wall like this and just
not move
because they'll be charging my oculus
likes
yes
no it's real man it's it's really real
so
salute to the team on that you know
again for we're going to transition as
well you know as far as um as we're
talking the pancake version all that
stuff but it's out now you know but put
the link to the chat y'all go check that
go wish list that you know again to get
it out to more people because as i'm
addict was saying you know not everybody
can do vr sometimes there's some people
that just they just can't dmail is one
of the games that is very accessible and
i feel you can but it's cool that the
studios also say you know what let's get
more gamers to play this right let's get
a pc version so i definitely want to
talk about that and um just in general
just like um now that that demo is out
we got on the road map you know i think
it's april 7th they're talking about
launch and stuff like that and did you
work specifically also on the the uh the
steam version is that or you have like
another team as well
yeah so the the
the team i've been most involved with
the last few months is their pc team
okay
so that's where i've been spending most
my life
producing time
getting it all together and like
it takes a lot of like testing and
playing
to get everything right
so there is no strict
like formula how to
how to translate the vr experience into
pc so you have to try and like do play
tests and
do
chance on that and
but i do i agree i think it's uh so for
the pc edition it's um
like a lot of people have a vr headset
but they don't have any friends with a
vr so this
you can actually invite your friends and
show them this really awesome game you
found and i think the magic of demo is a
lot in the
like you mentioned like the cooperation
oh yeah like strategizing
you you really have to talk things
through you can't use oh yeah
oh yeah it's in in one direction right
and that's still going to be there for
the pcb version
one not on the on the demo it's uh
actually pc to pc only so it's there is
no cross platform on the demo
and it's only one
one floor of the uh yeah the first
version of the
black star to guess you find the key
you find the exit and then the demo is
over so it's just a little bit of a
taste yes
but april 7th is going to be
cross platform would be our uh with
cross because of cross play with cross
play let's play yeah
good attic speaking of cross play
because we've seen cro you know
platforms cross play we've seen a lot of
that but we haven't really seen a lot of
cross play between
a platform and vr like it was that
something that was hard to do or like
because
i would think i don't know anything
about stuff like that but i don't think
i've heard very
too many games that's done something
like that to cross play between a vr
and like something like a pc
yeah
yeah i think it's not that common i
think
and i think it usually has been in the
case since it's happened it's it's been
the other way around it's there's been a
pc game that that the developer takes
into vr
i think this is one of the first vr
titles like vr first and
then uh
pc tomorrow
yeah
i i think it's a tremendous decision
because again you know we we love vr
that now i can say that
you know i'm in it now
called me out rightfully you know say
because he was the champion i tolerate
vr and attic tolerate vr but first i
love because i would push them we will
go to different shows like pax east and
um you know to to the e3 and um i will
push them to you know try it and i know
attic suffers from um the vertigo
sometimes with it
um the fact that you guys basically
pretty much eliminated it because you
know you could play it stationary
sitting down and shout out to the tilt
feature for my neck thank you thank you
dad whoever
thank you
it's not even the the stationary sitting
down like
what makes it work is the accessibility
of not having to turn too fast like you
can literally just look in one area like
games that really get me is the ones
that i have to like rotate my head right
or or that they they make you turn the
camera entirely like a 45 degree angle
those uh-uh not happening
that's why you'll like the hangout
addict because
you for you since you suffer from that
and a lot of people suffer this now a
lot of people are in the same boat as
you the teleport feature is something
you probably need to use when you look
at something you point and then i tried
that oh he's trying this too okay so i
got you
yeah he doesn't like it like that and i
think this game eliminates a lot of that
see
you guys talked about the casual but the
hardcore right
and you talked about the niche i think
you hit all those spaces i really think
you did you know and the hardcore is
going to bring in the casualties too and
the hardcore there's a lot of depth to
it because like like the stuff we're
saying is it's the strategizing because
it's like okay there's a synergy now
between you know bard and guardian he
gets the courage bar feeding the guy
goes out in front and there's a synergy
okay i got king he's altering his line
of sight is longer than everyone he can
hit that poison that i'm the guardian
that can't hit poison up the room like
it starts to you start to get into these
synergies where the hardcore go okay
there's challenges and i know one thing
for adam give it back to you king one
thing for attic that i know he loves is
as you progress you go from the first
dungeon you get the key you go and you
go in a second and it gets harder and
the enemies get tougher and then there's
immunities and things they could do to
you and then you get to the third level
it's like yo there's a boss fight and
you're fighting those crazy dudes with
the staff that's summoning cultists and
you it's crazy
you give us a similar
feeling that we have when we play raids
and destiny yeah that's not easy yeah
yeah continue
working together
um
my thing is the the seeing your friends
yeah you know a lot of times in vr it
feels isolated
and you guys have managed to remove the
isolation
of it
right so i can look over and i can see
my little quarter-hour dudes and then i
can showcase my little helmet
yes it's
it's it's so dope because i noticed in
the trailer shout out to me that was in
the trailer
shout out to resolution games for paying
king to be in the trailer yeah i thought
we was trying to get away from all
people that are bald and black don't
look alike
no no no that's if i remove my bed
that was you bag of the day you was dead
okay i got you i gotta go y'all didn't
know that i did the video for but um
when they turned the light on and then
he saw the rest of his friends
it's little things i think every when
you're on a great team and i think your
team probably really works really well
together because the harmonization
between all aspects of the game and
everybody took pride in different levels
of their of whatever they was tasked
with right
you could see from the characters um
whoever took great pride in character
designs i felt really good in my archer
yeah really good to the fact that i
zoomed in and i was looking at them and
they was like what are you doing we were
getting really could you please pick up
the key and go i'm like oh i'm looking
at my guy move
all right so but then you're listening
to the music
and then you're listening to okay touch
the key and it's everything just
harmonized straight through and i know
guys y'all probably think i'm blow
waiting but i want you to think about
how many games i do give this level of
high praise to and how many times i was
wrong you're gonna say zero so
think about it again this way right
if you guys
you know y'all and some y'all guys are
steam guys right you guys say y'all got
powerful pcs
go download the demo go check it out see
if i'm wrong i haven't played the pc
game yet but i did play the vr and the
the pc game which i believe uh has this
level of care to it
you guys will be partaking in something
very good and i think that's that that
would be something that'll probably push
you to vr yeah you could play with me
both that's what we're hoping for right
yeah yeah you guys like i said convert
some pc players into vr players here
yeah i'm trying to get those uh dlc har
cards
absolutely and that's why i said we got
to salute the the the pc demo you know
that's out now because again like you
said getting more people to try it
because we know player base means
everything right and when you guys have
that cross play with that group is cool
and i do want to salute you again on the
hangout that launched this week and i
got to check it out yeah you got to do
the hangout king because what it is is
again you like stranger things
boy this is a love letter today like you
go down there there's a changing room
you can put on your customization for
your little avatar all the things you
earned in game then what's so cool is
like
there's like an arcade they literally
made someone made an arcade of like
gauntlet they call it hauntlet and it's
like you could play it in vr it's an
arcade upright old school you could play
it then you've got a big area where
there's like a projector they're showing
the the discord server and you got the
um this archery like four guys you can
play archery like darts and all this
like it's a hangout it's huge and you
come in you're coming in with your
avatar everyone's talking and then the
last thing which is really cool it's got
you could make it public where anybody
could join it let me ask you real quick
what i asked this what's the you know
what the um the max player
account in a hangout or
i thought it would be the amount of
characters you can have in the game
that's crazy wow so you can hang out 12
people and then you can like
find some cool people to play with right
yeah oh that's cool you know what would
be cool
is if you guys could somehow get that
hangout to interact with the actual
board thing you could see people play
games like what would be create i wish
you at it what would be cool is like how
you got the two tables over on the
arcade side right
because this is how i work is so cool
like you go up to the demo section you
pick up the book of the adventure you
want to start right so you place it in
the middle of the table then everybody
puts their hand on the table like some
nights in the round to start the match
right but the thing is what would be
cool is the people who are in a session
i know this is probably a lot of
processing i'm asking a lot good stuff i
know but it would be cool if those
people who are already in a session
could then be shown on the table
playing so when you come into the
hangout he's like oh there's four people
already playing i see them you know not
that even they don't have to be moving
anything as long as it just shows okay
there's king there's attic that's solved
they had a game already
hey who who who want to group up and
let's get the four going like that i'm
just saying for future for the for the
roman maybe if it could be done
i think that would be cool
just a question because i had a list of
questions my last question
obviously we know pc the focus right now
obviously let's get it that's the next
focus
is there any form of a future map maybe
porting these to console or right now
you know it's not something that you
guys are really looking at i i'm not
asking for a yes or no i'm asking for
more of like is that something that you
guys might consider or right now just pc
is the thing
no i mean we want our games out there
right
possibility okay
like oh um because i okay i got it i
personally feel like it did good on vr
but i think this is gonna blow up on
steam yeah like absolutely blow up on
steve and i agree with addict in the
sense that once it blows up on steam and
people get to experience how cool this
game is you know
xbox and playstation brothers i say this
i'm gonna be the first person to say
um this might be the killer app for the
playstation 2 vr yes yes
this might be the kill because they're
gonna need some help for that no it's
it's not that it's just that it works so
well and it checks so many boxes no i'm
talking about playstation gonna need
some help
yeah well this is this one i'm saying
like if if any playstation reps are
listening and and they hear me in the
air shot you know um
i was down with you guys and i'm looking
at the the playstation vr
and the horsepower that is in this
machine the resolution everything that's
in there
um
i think the killer app is demio and i
think you'll really be really need to
someone said psvr has it in the chat
they they better um because
this this would get me to get a
playstation vr yeah but you talked about
two you talk about psvr too the new one
yeah well not the first one yeah i'm
talking about two i mean it goes already
on to my playstation 5 so yeah that
playstation 4 stuff is in the bush i
mean i'm talking about the newest latest
greatest right so if you want the newest
latest greatest to have this game that
can actually sell consoles that can
actually
move uh you know product i think this
game in itself can actually do that and
if you enable crossplay
playing cross play with somebody in
oculus and on steam stealing my
playstation and xbox and that
xbox sure yeah yeah xbox yeah that's
what i was gonna ask this stuff so what
what questions
in reference to all of this with peace
playstation vr you know they're coming
out with two i have the dev kits arrived
for uh just you know just just asking
for a friend you know
if you happen to be working on something
none of your business you know i mean
you know if you can't answer you can't
answer but you know if if you happen to
have definitely you gotta try i gotta
shoot a
they did shot release the the final yeah
like visuals right yes yes yes
and i'm so happy
yo he's media trained i love it that was
that was awesome that's fantastic
i'll see you at the finish line
so just out of curiosity because i know
there uh for those of you that chat that
don't know they're gonna implement a pvp
mode into this eventually oh my god
exactly
how do you guys is that going to be like
four players versus four players or one
versus one with four units or is it more
than four years is there anything you
could really go into on that can you
talk a little bit about the pv
[Music]
so
i don't know what's like i don't know
what i'm allowed to say
so you know okay
i think it's um it's gonna be a
reasonable
thing to play before playing or after
playing a regular d-mail session
maybe get a player let's just say that
okay okay listen he surprised us with 12
people he did it he gave us 12 with a
hangout
that's true that's true but i'll just
say like
okay
can i ask you what it's for relate this
listen listen let's extrapolate this
right extrapolate things
let's listen listen because he can't
talk about it yes right i know he can't
i want you to extrapolate this
they got 12 people in the hangouts and
what you explain to me is so many things
is going on eight people is not a
problem
think about that part right
that's a possibility so trust we do want
him back on so we don't want him to see
him no no we're not trying to get him
out
he's not going to harass a bit we you
know we can put the man at gunpoint
listen i extrapolate i listen i think
eight is less than 12. so i think that's
a good i mean he didn't confirm well we
could speculate on his behalf
all i can say is that it says like
saying that there's 12 people in the
hangout that shout out to the new social
heroes hangout that just dropped this
week go in there go get that go download
that go play that that's on your
metaquest vr go check that out right now
now the thing is like king would say if
there's 12 in there right
at minimum we know demio's four players
right so all we would say is it the hope
would be at least a 4v4 but again you
know we'll see what happens we'll see
what happens imagine if you guys were
able to do that on a little bit more
like a more broad scale
like the maps a little bigger you have
like a v8 like obviously this this is
this is like sequel talk stuff like that
but like that would be it say where like
you're actually having like a a huge
like massive scale battle with like four
other people this is gonna be dope yeah
it's gonna be fine because i listen i i
really now got fomo i really definitely
want to go upstairs and down yeah we
definitely rocking it last thing i do
want to talk about is the future and
like we talked we kind of touched on a
lot of things like you guys put the road
map out so that's public record you know
player hangout dropped you got the uh
again dbo pc edition april 7th right is
when we're talking for that pvp mode in
2022 though right it's coming out this
year pvp vote yes okay and i think there
will be like
some early
early yeah
okay
i think we're going to show it
around the launch of the pc edition
now you know what you guys got to do man
you got to come back you know what you
guys got to do man we see see we you
guys need to uh get get with the lords
and have a a dez versus the iron oh we
could do it again yeah it would be devs
versus lord be iron lord podcast versus
the depths
you can stream them
i could feel a little bit confident
before i lose
and bring the dev that we said the lead
one that runs with the sorcerer i want
to see no don't breathe
if he's rocking that mage i don't want
him there because he's using that mage
to his fullest ability i really don't
member can we get can we get like like
the beta test stop
appreciate you for giving us that man
again tremendous we're super pumped
we're super excited for the bowls and
last thing on the roadmap again that you
did talk about that i couldn't believe i
was excited because again we got
four adventures right now right
currently four right three three excuse
me three adventures right now um roots
of evil black sarcophagus rat king
now on the road map you guys say you got
two more adventures coming this year
oh yes
okay okay and last question you guys
with the roots of evil you announce the
bard clap the bar is amazing like salute
i have to admit i was skeptical to see
how it was going to play but it is true
support true support the buffs and all
that stuff is amazing shout out to
kaibatsu that he runs bart all the time
as a guardian i love running with bars
but my question is i know it's early you
just announced the character but in the
future is their thought of maybe even
adding even more another class or right
now you're kind of at the happy spot
yeah so
um nothing has been announced okay i
mean we're still building
content to the games
okay
so god bless really pushing this listen
man i guess
god shoot a shot on my favorite game
this this this is good stuff and it's a
lot of stuff it's you know it's not just
like uh you know they put out one game
and they didn't add to it there's a lot
of rich stuff that's going on in the
backgrounds i really cannot wait to see
what my archer gets and
how my archer can
really take over the world
and on the rail like i i was really
being serious on that like if you guys
want to do some kind of promotion thing
where you know us and you uh you know
with their play and that like we would
definitely be down for something like
that yeah
no doubt no doubt look this is
tremendous um i definitely want to give
you guys your flowers it's been great
also um you guys have another game out
too that i want to give some props to
you know really quick is uh blast on
blast on and um kind of like you know
what it is king is kind of like
a western one-on-one a futuristic
western one-on-one shooter so it's like
he's like you know about remember how
like back it was like the quicker and
the dead yeah but it's better like it
says like you know instead of the tech
take 10 10 paces to turn around and spin
the counter is like a ref the joint goes
up and then you got all these different
type of weapons and then this one you
could put a shield up so you can play
defense it's like esports it's
interesting it's esports futuristic
one-on-one wild west
yeah black stuff i gotta check blast off
blast on glaston
they have like a a western you know oh
you thought like old western yeah
yeah i definitely want to meet you at
high noon see who's the quick one of the
drivers they want to put out some
stuff that's the latest uh
game mode right
it's their quick draw quick draw oh my
god yeah yeah
fire
i'm a spaghetti western dude i grew up
back in the days with shane and all that
other stuff the good bad and ugly so
yeah i like that stuff
we're going to have to get something
going on where king got a dress up it's
a cowboy for a podcast i got no problem
with that
i got no problem with that as long as
it's for a good cause yeah don't duh
check it out check it out y'all i'm
gonna put it in the chat again
resolution games check out the like i
said they got a great lineup man great
lineup they're really killing it out
there
his questions let's get to his question
no doubt no doubt hold on one second um
attic we got to join i'll put it in
there if you could just put that for the
resolution games on that and before we
go we're going to get to the questions
that we always ask together before they
leave we're almost there we're almost
there but i do have to give them flowers
where do you want me to put this just no
just you can just spam that in the chat
just so people can know the games that
resolution games do because they get its
blast on it's demo they've got other
games too it's not just even though
demio's my i'm biased and it's my
favorite you know there's other stuff
going on but um i want to give you your
flowers in this thing before we get into
the final questions we asked for the
guests which is that what i consider
magic moments as a studio because like
you guys in my eyes like are just up and
coming like i i don't know if you guys
truly know like you guys
like the the arc that i we see you guys
going and um shout out to stockholm
studio i saw that advertisement oh my
the train station looks amazing i see
the old train i seen the office i'm like
oh they eat they doing big things right
now yeah but i want to give christmas
checks
whatever happened in december
with a better question for y'all or
whatever's going on because we're
hearing developers hit me up and they're
like look
we did like triple and that like things
things are doing going well right so the
magic moment though to me at 2021
is to see the accolades right
best vr game demo best co-op experience
demio all these different media outlets
to talk on the best pc vr game right and
then recently we had the dice awards you
know i'm saying you guys were nominated
i think it was um immersion immersive
reality game of the year for 2020 two
you guys were legally dominated now
shout out to lone echo two you won i
like when lone echoes cool i personally
would have had demio but i'm biased
that's that's me but at the end you
ain't biased that's just how it
should've [ __ ] i i think demi should
have won that you know what i'm saying
that's just me what demio that's where
it says that's where it's at but you
know sales talk you know yeah
you know we got to see the numbers too
you know what i'm saying nothing else i
honestly think demio yeah we all know
the numbers exactly we all know the
numbers
indicate king
is a bunch of misinformed people that
brought the wrong products it's all good
you know what it is it's just it's just
you know a little guy over here doing
this thing but like i said remember i
told you earlier tunnel vision don't
even worry about your peds just keep
knocking them down as you go forward no
doubt so what i was going to say again
with all these accolades you know final
question in wrist guard how has the team
what's the energy of this dude how's the
team been handling seeing this game get
all this praise from a lot of media
outlets and awards
yeah i know i mean it's it's uh of
course
like a big uh
you get a big push right both as uh for
the team the the people that's been with
this project since the
the very first like from the beginning
uh obviously the team has been growing a
lot
everyone is super psyched and also as a
company because uh demio is like
uh
our biggest hit so far so it's safe to
say devio is doing that they don't care
yeah yeah so that that
that really helps us right it
builds confidence it's uh it shows that
we're on to something here
oh you definitely are
definitely on or something we gotta hit
you with the on something emoji right
now like
i don't think you realize like i might
say
i'm a vr skeptic but i don't think you
understand how much we are the fact that
you got me
to
because what's funny is like you know i
got the quest too and it's like yeah all
right like you know it's cool but then
like
comics like yo there's this game demio
people say it's good man we need to try
i was like i guess so then he says this
to me and then i look around and i i
might i might end up being single
because i've neglected my girlfriend for
like the past five hours
bro it's real it's real
salute yeah because again you know you
that's what we do we playing it and you
know how many hours gone by and the
addiction the fun salute to the whole
team man you guys are killing it now
before you leave we got to ask the
question that we asked all the guests in
the realm before leave kind of a
tradition i need lord gustav's top five
video games or franchises of all time
that's a great great question
so i mentioned i was a nintendo
nintendo buff right yes
zelda on top
of that list when it comes to skywars
let's go yeah
so like
so many hours of great gameplay
um
but that's definitely on there
okay
like when it comes to like pc games
starcraft of course okay okay
actually you're not the first person to
say starcraft
i play the campaign because if i can't
talk my snap i don't know why i'm even
on there like
okay guess two that's two definitely top
five right and then uh
actually add one's worse
oh
advanced wars
yeah right
yes
yeah probably one of the games i spent
the most time in
my
classic and coming back right coming
back
yeah it's like it was supposed to launch
just before christmas i was super
psyched
and then they they pushed it to spring
this year so
looking forward to that all right so we
got advanced ones i have to say like
that was the
like the
probably one of the best pixel twist
games of all time and now they're like
reimagining it so yeah absolutely the
gameplay is still gonna be there right
absolutely
two more two more
stardew valley of course it's a
masterpiece in every sense of the world
i think like it's uh such an achievement
from one guy to build a game like that
yes
everything
by him classic stardew valley i like
that one more cool stuff one more so
that was four yeah but i have to say the
super mario
franchise
of course where it's it's where me and
my son we we
spent so many hours playing together he
is now building his own levels on like
uh nice and i've been playing it it was
the first game i played on my first
nintendo switch okay
can't go wrong with mario okay go over
america classic no doubt and the final
question
favorite console of all time and why
oh
that's good so uh
the game by the boss oh
first game boy
advantage break it down why why gay boy
advance break it down
yeah so i mean this i think the super
nintendo has like the uh
like visually it was was the best but
then like the game by advance is pretty
much that putting a bit more power right
and then
portable i i used to bring mine
everywhere
play all the time so absolutely
game boy events no doubt no doubt that
again we have the legendary gustavs
denmark producer at resolution games one
of the hottest highly anticipated
meta quest selling games with devio now
okay good at it i just want to point out
there's a couple people in the chat
asking you do not need a pc to play dmeo
on oculus correct
correct
yeah there's a local version like i said
that you get from from the uh the meta
quest store you can download that
directly wireless you're gonna have to
play with that you don't have to be
tethered to the pc if you want to do the
air link you don't have to do it like
this there's another version there but
you can do that and then obviously again
i'm gonna put it in the chat the um
steam version it's out right now there's
uh then actually nexfest right now right
uh which is the celebration of a lot of
upcoming games and you can if you hit
this link right now we put it in there
for again for the non-vr guys it's like
hey i'm not in the vr but if this was on
comp pc i'd try it there you go ain't no
excuse give it a shot and then yes
someone asked again they might they
probably missed it yes uh
consoles not on the on the table but
it's a possibility in the future
negotiations replacing you know
playstation
playstation throwing money around and if
they want my bucks they might have to
just talk to my people and resolution to
get their resolution up
listen you know at the end of the day
it's like you know one thing that gustav
said that i thought was very what's key
is that they want more people to play
the game right so when you when you're
supporting cross-platform you're doing
social hangouts you're doing it it's
encouraging more and and more people
play it then hopefully we get so you
know get more platforms together and me
personally i would love you know if the
steam one takes off i would love to see
this thing on like an xbox or xbox game
pass another thing you know microsoft do
what you gotta do drop the bag if you
need resolution games is outside
like so i'm just saying you guys need to
do while uh yeah and the exiting of this
interview may you
get those cosmetics up in these things
man
that's when it hits consoles listen
right now okay so listen they can get
two bags they can get the pancake
version on game pass right get that game
pass box and yo and please playstation
listen shout out y'all could get y'all
can lock down you know why are you
trying to get them acquired
listen
i gotta vote for the home team on one oh
you know better could also throw a bag
too if they would if they listen
what i'm voting for right i'm voting for
see they already got the oculus back let
them get some game pass back but you
already got that on steam right so game
pass ultimate let's hit that over there
you already know microsoft is on that
side
playstation
equation for stock he never stops
never stop man let's speak this into
existence
you're speaking it into existence so
microsoft can do gamepad okay
i want to i want to take a picture next
to the train with the demo with the
oculus i mean with the playstation vr
imagine if that ends up happening in the
future somehow and he's gonna he he
gonna be extra on this pocket i told you
guys
he's gonna say yeah he's gonna say he's
the problem i will be absolutely out of
control yes
anyway
you're already out of control absolutely
out of absolute pleasure as king said
more cosmetics if you want to put more
cosmetics in the game king is willing to
pay he's willing to do whatever he's
going to do
i need my archer to look great me
personally i would say i know that's a
developer thing behind you but um if you
get that board or the shirts on the team
shop how to make a team shop i would be
happy to support and buy those
and then you know adding what you would
what what's your final request for good
stuff on the way out
i want my tank to have 10 hp i'm joking
okay
so you just no i just
i just got you know i don't really want
anything i think the game besides the
stats thing i think the game's near
yeah
flawlessly
i
i
there's not too many games that i enjoy
more than demio like that's why i'm so
excited for the pc version because i
want to stream this game but it's hard
to stream it because i don't like the
way streaming on vr is present like
i don't like the way it looks okay but
once that hits on pc i think i'll stream
it a lot more on the iop chat twitch
channel the legendary gustav sten mark
resolution games on the way out brother
thank you so much for taking the time
with us an absolute pleasure we will be
charting you guys and paying attention
to all the things that deem you know
send our love to the studio stockholm
looking good and again wait thank you
for the topic
anyway enjoy your day brother thank you
so much have a good day thank you so
much guys thanks for having me
think you want to get you want to get
the uh super chats oh yeah we got a lot
of these yeah why could stuff leaves
all right so we have a two dollar super
chat raven blade i'm loving ellen ring
my first souls game i'm level 21 i think
i'm like level 18 or 19 but i thought it
said level two see that's why i need my
my glasses
then we have
and the entire thing give me a second
guys oh
no doubt no doubt and again for those
who just came in you know whatever we'll
put the links in there you know again
there's a 400 and some change in here
let's get these likes to share it out
let's get your friends involved yeah i'm
about to get so messy see i noticed
something that's not there but we're
going to talk about that today because
we have all these type these um
whatchamacallits all these topics but
it's one topic that's not there they
thought i'd change my mind no no no your
topic
we got it it's just that it couldn't fit
i got it on the docket no i know you
like where am i i know i know i got it
let me read these
we got a ten dollar super chat from
jesus i probably butchered that but you
know what man we're gonna move right
past that yeah uh i'm usually sleeping
during the podcast and let's do it
during the graveyard shift just want to
thank the lords for getting me through
half my shift every sunday absolutely so
you work that eight hour shift man
because we always give you four hours
every week
from dragon heart
yobe
i king we hear crickets from twitter
folks who swear they can bark at you put
dogs in a cage against the king lion of
the jungle only one will remain supreme
super trap from italian clowns all hell
of the king
all hell the king then we got a five
dollar super trap from k asante a
butcher
uh oh i got it right you're not hurt
that's right that's the homie the loot
for the iop for great vr talk i'm here
for it more folks should be paying
attention to this space content like
this definitely helps then we got a two
super chat from
let me breathe okay
cause so keeps i do i look bad i know
that you i appreciate the donation i
always watch iop during the week love
you guys
thank you brother salute thank you
brother and then we got a five dollar
super chat from let me make sure that
people okay five dollars from flame
don't take long for which queen to drive
me off the forge and wellspring weapons
drop near to be shown into a meat
grinder have a good show y'all
shout out to oh you be on flame don't
like the um you don't like the grinding
crafting you don't like to craft that at
all yeah well it is what if you don't
like grinding why are you even playing
destiny
from lord metro good to see king back
after skyward sword flute all right so i
do i do want to address these things
okay
i want to address last week's show okay
okay
first off let's let's address the
quote-unquote censoring there's no
censoring on the show last week
i get where you guys are coming from in
no way share perform was i shut down and
giving my opinion it's just a debate on
my opinion there's a difference between
my opinion being shut down and me being
muted and people debating my opinion it
was heated discussions and that's what
happens during the heat discussion no
way shape or form should you
look at us differently because of that
podcast we
you guys watch this podcast because we
disagree on topics
when we disagree on topics some of you i
felt was a little bit too much in the
comments section last week now i get
you're entitled to your opinion but you
can't appreciate the podcast for that
raw we don't agree on everything but
when it does happen occasionally you get
upset with it i did it i appreciate
see the the the what's what i'm looking
for
i appreciate the criticism because for
the most part i will say that none of
you were disrespectful in the comment
section i i got to appreciate it i got
to say this
last week um
i would have had a different take on it
to be honest with you because i don't
think and and i think
racial is is a component a small
component of it but i think economics
plays a huge part in it
um economically if you have a solid
foundation then you're able to pursue
your dreams in in a manner that uh is a
little bit more freedom right because
you have a base that you can fall back
on economically if you have to choose
between you know eating and and and and
starvation um a lot of times you're
gonna choose that eating right and a lot
of things that was said there uh lent to
the fact that uh it's a do or die
situation um and that has to do with
economics now sometimes it's not who you
know it's what you know but a lot of
times it's who you know to get you into
the door right so if people of um
we all go to the same university you got
to look at where everybody is connected
from so that's where the social aspect
comes into it so it was very nuanced in
the conversation and me being missed
from that one aspect of it actually lost
a large part of that conversation and i
don't think people would have took the
tone that they took last week because i
was reading you guys comments and i and
i felt that you guys was way off because
it was one voice that wasn't heard there
that could actually broad balance this
is why iop like right now we're missing
sovereign in a lot of this conversation
so you're missing a lot of our balance
so when we're short or we're down a
person you're going to miss one aspect
of our conversation and we actually
heavily lean on each other when it comes
to conversation so um i thought last
week's conversation was more economics
less racial but i understand exactly
from where it was coming from and what
it was talked about so we talked about
it in the background and no point in
time is addict ever silenced in anything
that he's saying because his words is
valuable especially to me because we
lean heavily on each other when it comes
to our thoughts and our opinions all
right so guys be very careful with the
stuff that you innuendo what you think
and what you assume because remember
when you assume you make
and me not a finishing i'll go after
addict
the comment section
never going to discourage anyone from
giving us criticism in the comments
section you are free to do that
uh but we will address it as we see fit
now i i do understand you a lot of you
when you read in the comment section
you're just concerned that you felt like
you know i might leave the podcast or
something like that what you saw last
week is nothing compared to what we've
done in raids like
we've done raids where some of us
haven't talked for days
so you know like cool off
a mild disagreement it wasn't even that
serious like
it's like i get it i appreciate now as
far as like the racial stuff i do
understand some of your concerns and
stuff like that you know i understand
that you know but at the end of the day
we can't speak for other people and if
they want to address certain opinions
that's their opinion
once again we come out openly every week
and say we give people we give people a
mic
respectfully to speak i don't personally
feel like anything ariel said was
disrespectful maybe he could have worded
stuff differently but i don't think he
was trying to be aggressive or
disrespectful in any way but i do
understand it could have came out a
little wrong not fair enough and i'm
glad you guys brought it up um for me
you know two things here one i want to
be very quick and i think one thing that
was missed uh last week on my side that
i actually agree with addict i think
people think like oh because you have an
opinion on something or you want change
because you're not happy with a
developer that you're not allowed to say
that if that was the case we wouldn't
have a podcast to have any topics about
right because we want to talk about
what's going on based on the information
presented so you're allowed to have an
opinion on the information that is
presented that's one way and that's fine
then there's another thought that's like
hey i i see where people's upset i don't
want to support a game or whatever
because of the information that's
presented and there's other people that
say you know hey i want a more nuanced
opinion i want a little bit more detail
why is this happening and that's it
there's no real wrong answer but that's
all i wanted to say on the subject me
and my man is good y'all ain't splitting
nothing up so um we already talk all the
time i think that's crazy
nothing yet yeah yeah not yet because we
gonna disagree you know what i'm saying
we got the ashley luca in here she's
heard us go crazy on ray's people ain't
being in the spot they're supposed to be
jimmy she had paid in the building
salute you play destiny you don't say we
or we have discussions or whatever
whatever
you could drop close in the chat if you
will yeah no doubt no doubt luca you you
you know how spicy you get with friends
when we disagree there's there's been
times where i'm running i was running a
raid i was running vlog with uh king
and some i don't listen i don't know
whose buddies they were
i was like
hello what are you guys doing like what
is going on right now so i definitely
understand
that raid rage because i feel like she's
she so listen right we we
we're in the raid right and it's at the
end you know i have to you you already
get to the end she struggles straight
through with us we're on a struggle bus
shout out to her as soon as she finished
she was like bye
i think the reason i wanted to address
it is i just i wasn't liking the attack
on us as a character outside the podcast
just because of one disagreement on the
podcast like that's why i need to
address it because you know attacking
individual members i say
everybody has a butthole nobody has to
hear it no you stupid anyway just want
to make sure jimmy jimmy hopefully he
can come back he got his thing but yeah
it looks a respectful disagreement
everybody's allowed to disagree it's
fine we're going to disagree and king
saul and i we all an addict we all got
different personalities oh yeah like you
said we gone disagree and that's why to
be honest why i love the podcast because
it's just like you know i i personally
not to disrespect any other podcast i
just don't like when everyone yeah we
all agree and we're all great
get along good luck and i mean that's
cool but for me i'd like when someone
challenged me and i'd be like nah fam
i'm not feeling that i'm like word okay
you know what i'm saying let's talk got
it
and the funny thing is like
hog you wouldn't even do nothing
different like cogs always try to be the
middle person we had
a lot of new people haven't heard me
when i yell or get my raise my voice
right so they're like oh what's going on
like like bro like people understand
like king no like y'all seeing a very
reserved version when i'm mad y'all know
how i get or what i'll be my feelings
and i'm passionate i my voice go up so i
think that's a combination of that as
well so they
they don't understand we all the same
person in different skins
anyway enough about that we got a poll i
just want to make sure jimmy champagne
is good i see him in there hopefully
he's got his mic joint and then i'll get
the super chat before you get the super
chat let me read the poll while you line
it up to super chat
last week pro results in the people
exclusive well spoken okay my words
right to the question with the release
and mostly positive review reception of
horizon forbidden west who do you rank
as playstation studios top game
developer the winner at 53 percent of
the vote
the messy lords
i don't care it's all about that organic
growth with bungie group so salute to
the messy lords who pulled this out
covered in that second place at 31 of
the vote was insomniac insomniac was
probably the real answer here third
place at 10 of the vote was naughty dog
wow nearly dog fell down in the third
place and then last place at only five
percent of the vote even though they got
that horizon out right now guerrilla
games people fraud alert oh you put a
front all right so king clearly you got
passionate about this topic you know
about the depaul in the realm fraud
alert on the realm what's going on no
it's fraud alert yeah on anybody that's
in that poll you confirmation bias dude
joe you you you recently biased dudes
prisoner at the moment and you man
naughty dog kept the lights on in that
building when he was about to shut the
doors down like when when when they were
looking at uh desperation situations
naughty dog is the ones that brought
y'all out of the fire y'all gonna
disrespect them and only give them 10
so i actually don't believe in you dudes
at all y'all are oh bungie right now
messy lunch you dudes anything they do
right now y'all about right now so i
understand who was voting and who was
the who doesn't have lineage to the
playstation brand
you guys are recently biased dudes so
whatever they do right now that's all
y'all concerned with so right now you're
concerned with bungie and stuff like
that that's cool and y'all want to talk
about just because spiderman came out
and they did a little you know sucker
punch stuff good fantastic don't you
ever forget who kept the lights on who
kept food on the table and who kept you
guys in the conversation and that's
naughty dog so naughty dog is the big
dogs over there don't you ever forget it
and you will understand it when uh last
of us three comes out y'all know exactly
what it is stop fronting you guys are
capping all day long sony gang all day
for real i haven't done all day bang
bang early that's right get in and lay
down y'all respect me
the doors are shut naughty dog street
early anyway look we got it going on
let's get to it y'all um oh actually
super chat's attic we we lined up yeah i
literally just brought them up too yeah
let's get those uh so we got a two
dollar super chat from no we got him we
gotta show some hetero chi uh you know i
butchered
him
oh he was in the chat
yeah what's funny is like it was the
same thing like king said like he sent
me a message like because i i respect
people that send me a message asking can
they join a party because it is kind of
rude if like you just joined a party but
i was like dude you don't have to like
here's the thing i don't maybe i should
have worked it better i don't care if we
don't play games but if i don't talk to
you and i look at my friends list and i
don't know who you are you're probably
gone so like it's just like you know but
people people are are welcome to join my
party it's just most the time they're
lost okay but okay so we got five
dollars super chat salute to the lords
what 97 medic game will come out when
horizon 3 comes out
okay okay okay all right
okay
moving on moving on
yourself from lord roughness
messy lords the horizon forbidden was
come out
oh my love move it over
shroom kingdom king baseball i don't
know what that is baseball baseball
baseball baseball baseball
is dominican republic baseball let's go
we got a two dollars picture from
necromancio zelia uh whatever
what's horizon forbidden west here they
being really messy man
look bad we will get into that we'll get
lost
then we got a
two dollar super chat from harness
are we allowed to drop codes in the chat
you can drop anything you guys think
anything you want in the chat you know
we definitely appreciate you as long as
it ain't for uh sites that's not
recommended yeah don't drop nothing like
that
but uh we got five dollars
you are all very influential see you
thursday king let let me this individual
everyone go and check out his channel he
understands some really
solid content you guys need to go and
check out i'll be on behind the sticks
this thursday so check that out
and then we got a five dollar super chat
from everborn saga don't confuse friends
with acquaintance if a friendship can
can't uh can withstand disagreements you
probably were never friends i think he
meant can't if a friendship can't
withstand disagreements you probably was
never friends
bar shout out to have a boy shout out
for the watch i mean
salute to him you already know i see you
did it up real big in paris i was
jealous
nah nah shout out to him eating in uh
me and wifey's favorite restaurant um
what is it and i said the favorite
restaurant and
rock
[Music]
he green chatted yeah yeah hold on hold
on hold on i see a member for 21 months
that's right the members don't show up
yeah let me get the members i got the
shout out
luca is the souls queen that is my from
soft seafoo
[Music]
[Laughter]
you gotta appreciate how she answers
things sometimes okay i love it i love
it we already know so funny man it's
it's it's it's it's
it's like that energy that you don't see
often like we love it we got the
location so look let's get to it we got
everything caught up in the business oh
oh oh okay
2 super chat uh three mode gp game pass
ultimate global hit that call geek
should be blessing us you already know
hold on let me get my man this is iop
clan he in the chat and the moderator my
boy dj otherwise known dj oros on xbox
david james rose the government out
there big fan of the show and long time
listener
then he goes question this is how he set
you up ray we raided today he's he over
this game he like
sinistan addict
d1 not a hardcore they got to do
everything
every day
six raids all the characters
he's like three characters yeah like
crap that's my man dj
rough up let's see you know what's funny
mm-hmm
you know how toxic i'm being on destiny
i've been loading into what what's that
new
game mode the um the weather right there
yeah i'm literally just sitting there
moving the controller a little bit every
now and then just complete the activity
that's toxic sir um ever born saga 2
chat witcher 3 greater than elder okay
all right let's get to it man we got a
lot of you in the bushes with that
i'm going to tell you right now you're
in the bushes with that i'm going to
about to
let's get to the main event
look y'all elden ring is outside
huge it's a soft topic you know huge
game one of the more highly anticipated
games and um yeah we got to talk about
it right the the metacritic is set the
world an open critic has set the world
of blaze said that like a 97 it's the
most talked about thing right now some
little controversy we'll get into that
as well for our technical performance
and stuff like that but overall for
those who play because i am not a souls
guy so i am going to be deferring we got
some awesome guests let's talk with the
action luca my sis she gets busy she
gets downs to these souls games so luca
i need to know like give me the feel
what's the energy on this elden ring
first of all i want to say anticipated
by who because people who are up
because the people who are buying this
game currently are only buying it
because of that 97
metacritic rating okay dark souls 3 had
what a hundred thousand people on steam
while alden ring has
had 800 000
concurrent users at one point so listen
i've seen a bunch of people on my
timeline people who have said i don't
like dark souls saying you know what
might have to pick up that elded ring
after they saw that 97 i'm like all
right
are you trying to like souls gank a
little bit like you don't want people in
the souls are you trying to keep this to
yourself what's going on no it's not she
said if he wasn't there from day one why
are you there now i get that but what
i'm saying is people allow themselves to
be swayed by a
no offense to them who didn't beat the
game yet
homeboy just dropped a witch queen code
in the chat oh wow shout out to hawkeye
but just in general look so like you
know you play these souls games i see
you rocking i see your timeline like
what's the feeling of this game how does
it feel to you are you enjoying it where
you at
all right so the game came out for
consoles on uh
technically on thursday night but i
wasn't going to stay up on so i started
playing
friday morning and when i say friday
morning i mean four a.m friday morning
and uh
i currently have 20 hours in over the
last
two days so i'm absolutely loving it i'm
grinding
a lot and uh it's a lot man it's very
very expansive the coolest thing about
it is that every area
is there's there's like something there
right because you know you're kind of
just wandering around most open worlds
are huge but empty but elgin ring is
huge and it's full of stuff to do
and it's full of different kinds of boss
encounters too and that's probably like
there are some areas that are like
blocked off
but you know there's also a lot of areas
that you can go to that you're not
supposed to be there right like there
there was multiple times where i
stumbled across an area where i know i'm
not supposed to be here because i just
got one shot you know
and it's overall it's just been pretty
cool there's some a lot of hidden areas
too secret areas areas that you can
completely miss if you weren't going in
that direction and happen to stumble
upon stumble upon it and i know most um
developers are
you know they want people to see
everything but fromsoft's like no we're
just gonna put this huge expansive area
here and if you don't find it you don't
find it but if you do
it's it's really special but at its core
eldon ring is a dark souls game
and if you don't like dark souls then i
don't think you would like this okay
that's me yeah i'm about to ask you that
i was going to ask you that but but um
i've actually pulled it before we before
we asked i just want to make jimmy
champagne mic check real quick just want
to make sure we can hear you brother
hear me yes just low turn up just turn
your volume up and you're good to go
oh much better my man
the lord of horror is here sounding good
go ahead
that 97 medic uh score see this is where
i i kind of disagree with your thoughts
on it because
dudes don't have the 79 dollars like
that you know like dudes
59 60 bucks whatever they don't have it
uh to just splurge like that so in a
month where they either gonna have to
choose horizon or something from
nintendo
or
i don't microsoft don't have anything um
and in this game that 97 gives you kind
of a good parachute to say i can jump
out the window on this and let me run
and go get it so i know you're saying
like uh dudes that i don't like soul
games but sometimes dudes want oh you
know people
keep saying dudes like only guys playing
them
uh they they want that reassurance that
they that they're kind of no failing
type of thing so i think yeah
a 97 metacritic gives people that
security in purchasing saying that well
you know nine times out of ten i'm going
to like it and a lot of people want to
be in
the now or in the group or in the
discussion because i've seen a lot of
youtubers all of a sudden now uh have
streams up and stuff like that for the
game so i just think it's um
just the security in that 97 and filling
part of a group will get people in in
more access of it
opposed to like dark souls from before
i actually see a different perspective
like
i do see where luke is coming from a lot
of people say that 97 and they just
gradually run towards it and i think
that's the reason a lot of these
companies care about that metacritic
score you you pop out a 90-plus game and
probably gonna double your sales just
off that alone yeah
and you know the thing about this one is
is like i the only thing i disagree with
luca is the standpoint that if you're a
dark souls fan
if you're not one you probably won't
like elden ring because i actually see a
lot of people that i know for a fact do
not like the dark souls formula that
have not stopped playing this game
uh i think maybe it's because like it's
a little bit more open than uh of their
uh dark souls it's not like executive i
saw you playing it and
might my foolish behind purchase secure
because it was game of the year crap and
all that other stuff and high metacritic
and all i fell into that goofy trap
and that game was sitting there right
but then i saw you playing this game and
i was like wow like
it gives a whole total different feeling
of expansion of world exploring of um
of it had a real different feel to it
and i had no thought in buying this game
but after seeing you stream this game
i had a a safety feel to it like okay i
can get by in this world i can play in
this world i can actually explore in
this world and i think that sings more
to me so that's why i want to play the
game okay i think i did want to say that
um can you just admit it that you picked
up sakuro based off it yeah i'm not
lying to you and having a having a high
metacritic explorer right which means
that it's completely plausible that
other people saw that high metacritic
score and picked up the game for that
very reason and not because they were
actually interested in it i disagree but
that's what every that's what everybody
gets
i disagree with this notion that people
like are holding their money close to
chest
because i see people
buying a lot of games throughout the
month games that like okay you know i
have extra money for this extra money
for that pretty much everyone on my
timeline has picked it up and it's like
people on my timeline at least have
admitted
yeah you know
i only picked it up because it scored
very high so it's like i i'm saying this
from a place of i've seen people say
this as well you know and then like
there have been other people who have
come out and said i hate the dark souls
formula i bought elden ring because of
that high metacritic and guess what i
hate elden ring even i'm just like
because it's like dark souls i'm like oh
okay yeah that makes 100 sense so i i
definitely think
that it's
a mix a mix of both because like people
like soccer and people like dealer who
don't have any interest in the other
souls games are enjoying elden ring and
zucker is a huge rpg guy yeah so's
dealer so they're enjoying the character
building aspect of it but there are
other people who are just like
i don't want to put in the time to get
better
or learn the mechanics and that's
perfectly fine the games are not for
everyone right yeah but it's like people
who've already played games in a similar
format with a similar formula
know they had a bad time with it and
then picked up eldon ring regardless
just because of that 97 and i heard
certain people who work in this industry
even came out and admitted that they are
biased towards from software and they'll
go ahead and give fromsoft a pass on
things that they wouldn't give a pass to
like sifu so it's just like for me i
find everything to be suspect and it's
like a 97 listen that's not out of the
realm of what from software could do
because there are games from darks from
dark i'm sorry from demon souls to
sakura have scored between an 89
and a 92
but like once you get over that 95
you're you're in a different
league
that's talking breath of the wild that's
talking red dead redemption that's
talking gta like you're on a different
level which means there's going to be a
different level of hype and a different
level of criticism that comes with that
as well
i want to get jimmy in um hold on
because we ain't got to want to make
sure i get his opinion on just the
initial thing you know
elder ring you picked it up how you
feeling about it what's the vibe what's
the energy of you playing another one
how much were you enjoying it i made the
big mistake of buying it
pre-ordering it through green man gaming
on pc and then i saw the stuttering and
stuttering is like the one thing i can't
deal with in games so i'm just waiting
until
there's some sort of patch for it
because i've been playing witch queen
but i'm excited to try it out i'm like a
dark souls fan so
i know i'm going to like it when i get
to it so i'm not like rushing you know
i'm like i want to enjoy it i'll wait
for them to fix the stuttering
and it's gonna be great so just for
clarity
pc version
this is where the issues
yeah okay yeah so
i mean i i keep going back and forth i
kind of just want to go up to the best
buy down the street
do the ps4 version because it runs at
60. but i'm like i i don't want to like
give them more money
because i already gave them money and
the game doesn't work like so that feels
weird mm-hmm
no because it's i didn't do it through
steam i did it through green gaming i
used wario 64's code it was like it made
the game like 40 bucks which was cool
but i was like you don't want to feel
like you're rewarded them for bad yeah
the same problem the funny thing is the
same problem is happening with dying
light too but they introduced it like
two weeks after the game came out after
everyone had moved on so
no one's even like coming after them
about it at all and they're just sitting
there not patching it so it the st
stuttering is a huge issue with games
that use directx 12
and
you have to do all these tricks like
forcing directx 11 like it's all placebo
type stuff that's why i don't buy pc
games yeah it's super annoying so i'm
just i'm waiting now i'm like i'm not
going to give them 60 more dollars
you i want to like state on why i think
certain people that don't normally like
uh games uh these type of
dark souls type of games i think the
reason that uh some of them are coming
around with this particular title is
because the open world sense like
they're not constantly being hit with
that you gotta pass these eight nights
these five archers like they have some
little in-betweens where they can find
gear they they can explore the world and
i think that's really opening them up to
the game a little bit more but then once
they get to the combat they hate matt
like completely hating that so you know
i like i feel like
from software has proven
that you can take the same formula find
tweak it
make it better and be just as successful
in opening up your game to other
incidences and other consumers than uh
than as then a franchise like final
fantasy that was like oh we're just
going to ditch the entire format
entirely because right we don't want to
work on it and i feel like people need
to look at that a little bit more
because when i look at something like
final fantasy it's a show of what it
used to be to me but then i look at
something like persona and i'm like you
could have been that if you would have
stuck to your guns and evolved your
gameplay instead of ditching it and
making new gameplay but then when i see
something like eldon ring i'm like this
is a studio i don't believe in the 97
metacritical we'll get into that later
but this is a studio
that took their formula kept redefining
it over and over again and now they
probably have the best game they've ever
made and i want to open up on that
because
the question i have because you know i
am not the slowest guy
for i i'm okay i'm called my skin shout
out to you bob's got to try everyone
tries to pressure me i know the type of
games i like that is not my style of
game but salute to everybody who's
getting it in and salute to what looks
good for you for not being pressured yes
you know i felt i folded it like a deck
of crap
why you got that mouth fix your mouth
you can't be folded with that body
we got food
[Laughter]
i see it man i see the anticipation i'm
seeing what luke was saying some people
who were like yo you know what i'm going
to give this one a shot and i want to
shout out my co-host on defining duke
maddie mr maddie plays because he says
something that really hit me and he's
like look how
this thing
is like a skyrim feel
it does have a lot of skyrim and now
when you start talking skyrim
like that's god tim
let me give you an example called what i
had
on a horse man just going around killing
people and then i come across this dude
on a ledge
and so i do the dark souls thing i fold
it i fold it i kill it and then he turns
into a bear and the bear kills me
but right now luka like
is it is is that too much hyperbole is
it is it in that skyrim class is the
feel like that oh i can definitely see
some uh skyrim elements especially with
the
open world and the fact that there's
dragons and the exploration and coming
upon new things i i can definitely see
that
um okay so i don't think it's hyperbole
you know i i think elder ring from what
i've played of it is definitely a great
game
uh in a lot of ways they've refined
the dark source dark souls formula you
know and a lot of things that we had
complaints about in earlier games like
the lack of a jump button
or
uh oh this
where where can i rest you know like i'm
about to encounter a very difficult
enemy like oh okay here's a sight of
grace right here so you're good you
don't have to worry about that um
they've made it so
you know i do understand the whole
concept of it being the most accessible
one because you know there's these
things called summons that you can use
help that can help you out uh with the
bosses
i've seen atticus though yeah i like
those yeah those are the things and
there's there's different ones as well
like i have one that can
that can poison
i can poison so you can't do that laugh
look
that can poison enemies and it's kind of
made um some of the boss fights a joke
but you've been it was just been very
very funny to me but you know and and
also they've made it so people cannot
invade your world
unless you
want them to invade your world
essentially which is the most different
from wait wait wait wait wait wait come
on come on let's bring that back
select the rewire wait a second so you
mean if jimmy champagne is playing and
he don't he don't hit that button it'll
block me out i could just jump in his
world and just act up yeah
no no no not like that you're good i
like that
he's totally like
death
you're good for elden ring like alden
ring unlike like for dark souls demon
souls
um and bloodborne right
if you were playing online people could
invade you yeah literally
so what does the invader do i'm with
king yeah
he fights you he'll kill you listen i
need clarification can i be michael
myers and jimmy champion as well he can
only be michael meyers in his world if
he allows people to invade his world
okay so if he don't hit that button to
block me out of there
i could just show up do he know that i'm
in this world is it some alert yes is it
like king is out here
the king is outside
yeah it all it all
oh you have turned this into something
totally different
i need to harass my friends like i
really listen guys i want y'all to add
me i want everybody in the world to hear
this earshot add me right now and i'm
going to slide up into your world pool
man king talking all this nonsense he
about to get folded everywhere out here
king is outside can't jump into work
there's no problem that you fold me up
but when i get strong enough
i'm gonna be
i guess my question is okay so what is
the gameplay loop for the invader like
what is he come in and steal items like
what is the loop for that like he he
i don't know like in other ones like
they they reward you in certain places
that luca would probably be a person to
add asked it question answer this
because i'm gonna be real with you
bloodborne all of them like i've like i
don't got time for none of that smoke i
played all that offline like i'm not
dealing with no red people showing up
and trying to hit me up like the red
kids
and that's completely understandable
especially
um given how punishing these games can
be and like how far away
uh this rest points could be so
essentially i don't know how it is for
you to get you lacking
i can come in there with the red hoodie
on
you don't be the craziest thing king you
will get the most broken builds evading
your world like there's no chance of
winning you're just gonna you might as
well jump off the cliff but luke you
guys are just deciding you know my horse
he's scared because that sounds like
griefing like like look
look what could he like what is the loop
though like what if you defend then what
do i get a chance to steal what you
gotta get like a bunch of runes like a
bunch of reasons i'm about this i'm
about this this whole busted into
people's world life oh i'm going
this is going to be so much fun y'all
done started a whole hold up
and the fact i can stream this
i can i can hit the twitter the the
stream on twitch i'm gonna be a menace
to society
i do want luca to answer that question
because i really don't know what the
other ones have been
so for the other ones um you would join
a faction okay and depending on what
faction you joined is the material you
would get after you killed someone if
you invaded them now if they were able
to defend themselves they would get that
material got you okay okay okay so we
could put king down i mean also it was
definitely griefing like that's 100
but there are instances where it's like
you'll invade somebody's world and they
have like four other people with them
because they're doing co-op so you're
like they're like oh what's good
roughness when you see the squad coming
on our horses the four horsemen
you're gonna see us on top of the
mountain you're gonna hear
[Laughter]
we we coming into your world we're gonna
catch you when you lacking and you know
and the thing is though when king shows
up to your world he does not come in
peace yeah no i do not come in people
start a war all day
that's the side that's the call
now
let's transition this is hilarious this
actually sounds really fun i can't front
now the thing is the thing is now it's
not fun trust me
yeah and also uh invaders are ignored by
the enemies that's what uh oh my god
that's like so it's like gambit
so it's
yes and they show up right so it's kind
of like you could end up being invaded
while you're fighting a huge group of
enemies in the group and you're just
that's so funny this is definitely
i i've literally been invaded in
previous souls games when i have been
online and they'll sit on the sideline
and i'm seeing them and they'll wait for
me to fight it i'm like at least you had
the respect to wait for me to kill them
i'm not going to wait
to you in the middle of the mix and i'm
just going to come up behind you and i'm
gonna hit you with the toby maguire stab
like
those were the best youtube videos back
in the day like yeah you could do that
in dark souls yes this is gonna be
y'all y'all deserve this 97 y'all get a
97 offer oh daddy deserve it
all for the i can ju and i could come in
with three other dudes
we're going to run rip shots no just one
on one
the hosts can have people with them the
host can have people with them oh okay
okay so i'm saying like the invader is
going to be the one who ends up being
jumped oh okay so i can come into the
world and you can have three people
already this yeah
so you're like a selective robber like
when you yeah oh of course who gonna go
inside the bank with five cops
you got the patrol man with the square
badge you can catch this work
if i catch you messing around with a
boss all you're gonna see all you gonna
hear is [ __ ]
i'm gonna come right off the bushes i'm
like
and i'm gonna get you while the boss got
you loaded get the room this is gonna be
so you you you justin you're jixing for
roads
okay okay
all my level is gonna be just straight
from the jokes all right so let's get
into the second part and jimmy kind of
alluded to this which is um you know
the fact that we're hearing there are
technical issues right you know i want
to shout out uh jess gordon for windows
centrally that article out and
apparently at least i know the xbox
version the online portion the co-op was
like lit almost non-functional there was
some type of network issues apparently
it was a mismatch version issue and they
had to fix it on the back end now for my
understanding shout out to um brad
rossetti and those guys on the platform
the ui side they did make a fix and that
that is um out now and i think it is
resolved now but shout out to the xbox
community let me know xbox guys if you
were able to do the co-op and all that
stuff because i heard that was fixed
like yesterday people saying it's good
now okay cool that's what i heard but
that was i was an issue for a little
while then kind of what jimmy was saying
which is the um
the pc version now that's where i'm
really
hearing is it jimmy shaking his head
yeah he's sorry open up jimmy so like
explain specifically it just it just
stutters like what is the performance
issues going on
if you want to see what it looks like
the first four like 40 seconds of ign's
review is like you know like glamour
shots and when watch the background when
the camera pans you see it's not smooth
like it like
it looks like it just micro freezes for
like less than a second but it happens
when you're running you can see it in
that review too there's it's in like any
review that use the pc version
and apparently the 1.02 patch or
whatever the day one patch made it even
worse
the point where when you go into new
areas it would like stutter for a full
second and like freeze and the issue is
really because
it's anytime something new comes into
the game it grabs that animation or it
grabs that texture and then it like
stores it so that it can load it faster
next time but the act of doing that i
guess makes it stutter
horizon zero dawn is the only game that
i played that did it right
where you would load up the game and the
first time you loaded it up or every
time they passed it or every time you
update your driver it would know that it
was like dealing with like a new cache
so do it all in the background before
you can start the game
and no other game does this i don't know
why so it's like a frog
i'm sorry yeah it's super annoying it's
i don't i don't know why i like it
happens with every game why they don't
just do this shader cache before but
directx 12 the reason all these
developers are using it is because it
gives you an insane frame rate boost
like
you could go from 40 frames per second
to like 100 sometimes a certain game so
it's like there is a performance gain
from it but the stuttering issue is bad
and then you it usually also is made
worse by anti-cheat which is what
happened dying light i guess they fixed
that somehow but they made that game
worse too and then now
this game is having issues with
easy anti-cheat because people were able
to turn it off and it reduced the
stuttering a lot but the stuttering
stuff oh okay if you're sensitive to
stuttering it'll be terrible some people
are just kind of like used to it i guess
or they don't know it's there they're
just that's got to be awful in a souls
game which requires precise timing
blocking powering jumping in a boss and
you get in stutters right like
yeah and then my second question besides
that is again because i'm not familiar
with the series on pc like other
versions of dark souls games on pc where
they're always kind of technical issues
initially and then resolve like what's
the his the history of souls games on pc
if if there isn't so dark souls 1 was
horrible when it came out
this guy
made a fix for it that was literally
just like editing the
settings file and that fixed it so that
was great okay dark souls 2 flawless
when it came out i played it was great
they did that re-released version it was
great dark souls 3 i got the game early
and it was excellent ran great
sakura was like perfect perfect pc port
like no issues at all
and just it's this is the first one to
use directx 12. uh
okay and i think the open world
obviously there's a bunch of different
biomes and stuff that's
also contributing it should be an easy
fix they just gotta do it and then
i'll jump into the game but it's so
irritating because every game lately has
had this problem like outriders had it
control had it like going way back every
game that's on pc has this issue
stay strong
shout out to mixers for fixing that you
know that's my heart he didn't got that
right he loves dicks
you know
understands how to port pc i mean
playstation games over properly without
the stuttering dude their avengers port
is like when that game came out and pc
oh that was embarrassing i think it was
diamond did it whoever i think no no no
no no nexus didn't do that
you ain't captain
so jimmy let me ask you a question
before i open it up again to etiquette
and look at everything um i know shout
out to my last stand media brother
dustin um
i wanted to ask have you guys because i
know he's dark souls to the core like
have you guys tried co-op well he's
staying on playstation because i was
going to do it he's on playstation okay
um
i i literally booted the game up i saw
the stuttering and i was like alt f4
i'll play this one
[Laughter]
because i spent so much time trying to
fix dying light like i said literally
get home from work right i'd be like all
right i got like three hours to like
play some games i'd spend like two hours
trying to fix the game and then i just
go to bed and be like oh this is so
annoying i'm like why am i doing tech
support
jimmy jimmy why are you putting yourself
through i just
i just want to point out
everything you've been saying everything
you've been saying
is the exact same reason i don't review
nothing on pc i don't ask for pc codes
they will literally offer me a game i've
been hyped for and it would be pc we got
a pc code i'll wait for the game to come
out like
i lose either way because i used to get
in this trap where the p you know pc
versions of every game they're always
messy at launch so i'd be like all right
i'll buy it on ps4 or ps3 or whatever
back in the day and
then the steam sale comes up later and i
get the urge to replay the game so i buy
the game again on computer and then i
start it i play like 45 minutes and i'm
like cool got my fill and then i never
play it again
this is the destructive cycle listen he
identified the problem all he has to do
is isolate it and remove himself from
the situation the thing is though is the
way he's talking i don't think he thinks
it's the most oh he's young so he's at
the admission phase he's at the ambition
phase
he understands
what's going on
and i was like surely this game will run
right i'm like all these like destiny
two wish creams flawless it's great you
know what's crazy speaking of destiny i
know we're about to about to talk about
that
the destiny community i'm sure jimmy
you've known we've always been like day
one ain't working right day one yeah
they're working right
now this is the very first time where i
would people who's calling me yo you
know that's the service like dude i've
been playing synthetic
yeah because i do i do want to like
touch on that when we get to that part
yeah that'll finish it let's let's get
to it so like again we we had the pc
aspect let me get luca for console now
luka you're playing it on on xbox or
place it where are you playing it just
want to clarify i'm playing on ps5 oh
she's playing on ps4 okay great yeah are
you playing the ps4 version
i'm playing the ps5 version and yes it
has uh some stuttering and some frame
drops i've noticed that okay you know
jim says you know y'all could play the
ps4 version and cut that out
and if there is one i don't know if
that's confirmed no no no no no
that's the thing oh it is confirmed
on ps4 yeah because it's the frame rate
is lost
that i didn't know oh so
yeah
play the ps4 version on your ps5 so it's
fine yeah it it it don't matter you know
the same thing
i wanna should ever
start carrying about 60 frames per
second that's what that's right ruined
my life
that i like i agree i'll agree
but the thing is jimmy is i'm okay with
it ruining my life because that the the
the difference in game play is night and
day like i for the most part when it
comes to like people are like oh attic
you playing with this setting with that
setting like i don't care about none of
that but when it comes to that
that
60 frames i care about that like when
you play when i play destiny now that
obviously there are games i will feel
like you know bg's very famous for
saying that some games at 30 feel a lot
better than other games at 30. i think
it's more like because they're locked
but when it comes to when i play destiny
2 and maybe it's more of the field of
view than anything else maybe that has
something to do with it but when i play
destiny
and i
saw that pc performance
me and cognito did not go back to
consoles until that's luca was mad at me
she was like you apparently declared and
i was like y'all
a lot of people on our clan when we was
on console yeah we had bands in the
console clan but this is what i knew it
was real though i left the light on i
was like a motel six i never left i
stayed right in the chat bro you stood
tall you was
i was the first person to play that
joint into 60 frames and i walked away
from it said i will never touch that
i will never do that again that's not
good
he was the first person to touch it and
he was the light and he was the first
person to make a mistake you know what i
found out
he chose squad over here yeah
it was so disgusting this is just for
you in fact give me the follower
put that on and break it listen when
when that patch came back that's when he
came back he's like yeah the next day
like he never left me
but here's the thing you know what i
knew i it was it was working it was one
time i was putting clips
you know what i do it was working with
when luca hit me and she seen one of my
pc clips of like this replay she said oh
god i do see how much faster than
i think some of it has to do with that
you know the fps but i think a lot of it
has to do with that that slider man yeah
oh god
i think a lot of people realize how
relevant that is
i don't know why every game is like
every game has a slider on pc but every
game i've played recently it's in first
person they set it to like 70 or 75.
like why i wouldn't
right now that destiny only goes up to
105 and not 120.
that's also very weird yeah yeah but
let's focus on back on the other joint
with all with ellen wrangler finish up
but um yeah so just definitely went off
screen yeah we went off screen it was a
good one because we got destiny this is
that's why i'm glad
luke lady lucas here lord jimmy
champagne here these are two unique
guests that like both so it's cool to
get your perspective that's rare i'll be
honest with you was saying we're
unicorns yeah you guys like unicorns
like to have because usually it's a very
divisive community but overall luca like
you said your experience you saw some
things but not as far as performance or
bugs or glitches but anything too crazy
and are there any different modes i was
going to ask you guys like is it like a
performance more or less okay there's a
quality mode but like don't play in
quality mode because that's having worse
issues
it goes between like 30
and 60 in quality mode like
and then well like performance mode is
between 45 and 60 which is more
consistent okay okay not fair not not
great but yeah great i heard when you
look at the sky 60.
when you look at the sky at 60 but when
you look
yeah and it's like for me um listen i
played
uh dark souls the first one on ps3
and
that game dropped like 13 frames you
know what i mean so it's like i get it
but at the same time it's 20 22. and i
just think stuff like that's
unacceptable oh yeah absolutely
no doubt yeah releasing games like 80
done is like the thing now i get for
some reason i don't like it's so
annoying like i'm done buying games at
launch pretty much i'm just gonna
already check the steam discussions and
be like how many posts are there
complaining about stuttering and that's
how i decide if i'm gonna wait
i'm i'm with you i hear you so i want to
get attic before we move on
i see you streaming liking it you know
over hot you're funny overall attic you
know what's the vibe man like you
sticking with it is it has it exceeded
the hype so far away yet
i will say that this game
is
the best it's the best they've ever made
and i like i'm one of the people that
like sakura the most now i do need to go
back and replay dark souls 3 because i
never fully beat that game
uh but you know i played i beat dark
souls 1 dark souls 2.
and it's just like
sacro up until now was the best i've
ever and i really enjoyed bloodborne but
like what makes this is just that i'm on
the you know you're you're riding down
on the horse and you just come across a
random dungeon and then just some random
dude in there some random boss and
apparently they have bosses that roam
the the map at night
and it's just like
when i'm playing this i can feel the
quality like i can feel how much time
they spend to it like maybe
this has a lot to do with uh the dude
the george dude from the game of thrones
didn't he design the world no no no he
just came through and gave the outline
for the story
oh just the story i thought he helped
design the world but i mean
even knowing that he didn't do that it
doesn't
this is definitely something that you
could see and know it's a from software
kind of world like they've always been a
very fantastic job with this i know a
lot of people are like oh you know why
you think it's like the skyrim uh breath
of the wild like i i think people they
get like kind of mixed up when people
say something's like a breath of the
wild or something they just mean like it
feels like you could do whatever you
want type of sensation not necessarily
it's breath of the wild gotcha like when
when i'm going around and i find like i
said i killed a random enemy and a damn
bear showed up for no reason like you
don't get that kind of experience in a
lot of games and you know do do you want
to just go ahead and get into the
performance you want me just talk about
that yeah just get your bars off like
i feel like
the metacritic of this game and the
reviews of this game first off i want to
point out it's another game that uh mad
issues happening you know no one wanted
to put a spotlight on it oh
okay okay so it was horizon now it's
this regardless how it is i don't think
horizon's a little different than this i
think this is worse all right so hold on
hold on because
i was gonna say i was gonna say because
you're gonna like the poll question but
um are you implying lord addict that
because of a studio's pedigree
that
they'd be more receptive to getting a a
pass for their bugs versus other studios
with less i think
i think it's a mixture of a bunch of
different factors i think one thing is
depending on how open that publisher
developer is to criticism
because it's been very open that there
are some publishers not gonna point
eddie out that
they don't like you criticizing their
game too much and they will blacklist
you all over it uh i think it has to do
with this is a sump from software game
like lucas said this is not for everyone
right so i find it hard to believe
that people are lighting up in corners
that don't like soft from software games
ask and review this game
so i think
this is one of those particular things
where you're getting the majority of
people reviewing this game they're from
software fans i don't think there's a
lot of non-fun software fans reviewing
it so you're going to naturally have a
higher curve because people that like
this genre
it's like it's like equivalent to having
like a non-racer reviewing racing games
you have that all the time i just
reviewed forza horizon 5. i don't like
racing games right you have people
reviewing a variety of different games
that they don't like but when it comes
to from software games i feel like the
reason they naturally review higher is
because they're being reviewed by people
that love and are very passionate about
that that genre uh when it comes to
the 97 look i'm not saying that this
game was shouldn't have rated high okay
92 93 94 all day long i just don't
understand how some people went through
this game and didn't see the stutters
and didn't see like jimmy like jimmy
can't play right the massive issues and
i understand yeah like jimmy ain't
feeling like it's a 97 is what you're
saying
once they said i can invade your world
and get you when you at your weak point
kill a beast while he wound it i love
that 97 all day
like they they that don't play souls
games don't like soul games like uh jake
paul dino our friend oh shout out
he does not like souls games he like
starts them he plays them and he never
gets hooked he was like mega hooked up
really and i think that's because of
this open world that they designed
because like when you play these other
games i'm not going to lie like
88 of the time you're grinding fighting
you're in encounters all the time you
can literally just
just ride around on your horse and never
encounter you sure you ain't going
nowhere like it's going to be a a a
it's going to be a horse singular at
that point but like there there is a lot
of scenarios where you're not happy to
engage in these encounters 24 7. and
when it comes to the like you know the
the performance things
it's like i said man like i do feel like
we need to take
these companies in terms of
the the performance of these games and
especially when games are game breaking
uh you know we need to take it more
seriously and i i see a lot of people
talking about whether or not you can
review a game not beating it apparently
like a a lot of the people that played
eldon ring didn't beat the game and they
reviewed it like there was a lot of
people
so
you know i don't know if you guys want
to tackle that let's let's let's open it
up because we don't want to silence at
it
[Laughter]
okay but all right before we get to that
part because we're going to be really
messy because i'm going to jump in oh
lord
let's let's get lucas whole party that's
not going to
yeah i want to get luca on that too i'm
going to be extremely messy with that
metacritic the review the the the skill
kind of stuff what i talk about and then
obviously the the second part of before
we go
what'd you feel
luke is there she stepped away okay so
our so what part are we talking about
first meta predict being skewed or
review games without finishing that
let's do both let's just go for it okay
so yeah i've been saying this for quite
some time i think metacritic uh is
skewed i because they rate some sites
higher i think ign is higher than other
sites smaller sites as well um i also
think reviews in general are skewed
because it's like addict was saying i
agree with him 100
these are from sloth fans reviewing from
soft games and i think that's a big
reason why the game got a 97 you know
and why these games continue to rate
high i mean like from software is my
favorite developer and i love all of
their games genuinely genuinely but you
know when i saw that 97 i was like oh
that's kind of hmm you know like that's
kind of weird
that that caught me off guard
it really caught me off guard because
like i wasn't going to say anything on
twitter because you know they weren't
going to have me looking silly like
you know some of these people say in
harassment
horizon was going to get a 93 and you
know but uh anyway so they weren't going
to have me looking silly so i was just
like oh i'll wait but i figured it would
score in line of what the souls games
get so between 89 and 92. 97 i was just
like um all right especially with the
issues the game has been having as well
and
in terms of performance and everything
like that and also it's like in in a lot
of ways it's still
like okay from a art artistic standpoint
and environmental storytelling the game
is very beautiful right but it's also
lacking in terms of graphic and
especially that character creator that
character creator let's talk about it
it's really really bad like
listen i was messing around with a
little bit you can't make anyone who's
asian or black or any other ethnicity
you know so it's just like the skin
tones are extremely off and it's just
it's it's better than what it's been in
the past but it's still
far behind and miyazaki-san even came
through and he was just like yeah we did
feel pressure after seeing demon souls
remake you know we did and i'm glad they
did i'm glad they felt that pressure
because i'm hoping that maybe one day
they'll invest in making it a little bit
better in that term or doing something
to update the graphics you know what i
mean and it's just like in my opinion
it's like
because they continue to rate so highly
yes it's good that they are appealing to
their fan base and i i appreciate that i
i appreciate them not changing things to
try to appeal to a mass audience and
just doing things for the fans but at
the same time it's kind of like because
you have the same fans you know if your
fans are willing to let things go or
disregard certain things that perhaps
you should be working on you know so
it's just for me she's on fire
i just i just
i i'm really enjoying the game and i do
think it's beautiful but i just think
that in 2022 like you know
they'd be sh they should definitely be
doing a little bit more when it comes to
performance when it comes to graphics
and especially that character creator
now um wait so what was the second
aspect oh i listen i know this may be
controversial but
i really think you should beat a game
before you review it um i understand
that given the nature of this game and
how to be honest even though you can go
to the bosses because it tells you where
to go uh the
those bosses are very difficult the main
ones and i kind of feel like it's more
like a hey
stop what you're doing you can't beat
this main boss right now go explore our
huge expansive world you know so i
completely understand why they weren't
able to finish it especially given i
think they were given like a week or so
to be able to probably
you know i i get that but at the same
time
like how can you give a game a 10 out of
10 if you haven't beaten the game
that's so weird to me i i agree oh and
then one more thing because and this is
like the main guy right after yeah yeah
people are saying no no it's fine people
are saying no it's fine no it's fine
okay imagine
imagine if
reviewers
had reviewed mass effect 3.
yo you used my example i just said this
to attic on a phone call remember attic
i used that
that's so crazy luke is doing that guy
continue
mass effect 3 didn't play that ending
and then after the review got out
preached played that ending the original
ending was like oh oh no
fantastic point luca an ending of a game
can completely change your perspective
of the game
and to the opposite effect where
outside games where they kind of started
out yeah mediocre and then there's like
a second half of the game where it just
takes off and they transform into this
amazing thing and you're like oh my god
and the ending is great you're like wow
so i get your point attic jump in and
then we gotta give jimmy
i gave this example when luca when i was
watching this gum cast it's equivalent
of like you know you use mass effect
like imagine
reviewing
uh shadow of a shadow of shadow of war
uh the elders not out the mordor sequel
the mordor shadow of war
and then you you review it before they
make you do that crazy grind that they
had to patch out of the entire game
so it's just like obviously that game
probably would have been nine tens out
of tens but a lot of people
deducted because of that ridiculous
grind they made you do i didn't have an
issue with the grind right because i
like i was really heavy on like leveling
up my people so i was able to do a lot
of that already but imagine like just
going in there and be like not taking
that part of the game into consideration
like imagine like reviewing a game that
has like a really bad offset ending or
really bad cliffhanger that doesn't
answer anything like a lot of the big
questions you have in games for the most
part in story telling the narrative are
answered in the last 20 percent of the
game and imagine you and you're
reviewing a game on eighty percent of
the game and give it
is remember what was that all metal gear
king that we loved i believe it launched
with ps2 as a graphical fidelity of
kojima you could throw it was on the
ship the demo was on the ship you could
throw the bodies too right solid two
yeah if you remember at the time about
40 to 50 percent of the game it was a
controversial thing right you played 45
i think after you got beat big shell or
whatever the name of the ball was right
raiden was introduced was who was
unknown to everyone at the time it's way
more than that it's like 90 percent
you're right you play like the tutorial
as snake and that's sweet
and you go to raiding and you're playing
raiden yeah that's a good point it goes
to show you how like a review can skew
because if there's a major inflection
point but jim i'm gonna give you a balls
on these two points you know the
metacritic stuff you know and then
obviously the bug stuff like but what's
your feeling on both things that we're
talking about
the technical side of it i don't
understand how there's no standard
across the board for
if we're going to ding games on
technical issues because you see stuff
like prey come out right right and
ign gave that game like a four or
something because of technical issues
and then when they fixed it they bumped
the score back up but that hurt that
game a lot and i would that's what i was
making the point on
uh
on dying like two sure that game had a
lot of issues but i felt like the
reviews impacted the issues and i felt
like when it come to like horrible right
yeah that's a great nothing people are
not talking about whatever
i'm going through
that reason why as soon as jimmy is
finished
so yeah no i don't i just think there
should be some sort of standard for if
we're going to talk about technical
issues and on the metacritic thing right
like hitting the review embargo they
didn't have enough time to be created i
i think you can make a review where you
say i didn't beat the game here's my
review based on what i played right at
the beginning some of you reviewers are
hiding that fact which is bad and
why do reviews and progress exist if
they're not going to use them for
certain games right like because what
sounds better review in progress or
review
you're just trying to build numbers
trying to be for quality review or
whatever like i it shows the lack of
confidence in your review and how bad
people want to read it if you're saying
well we got to get it out the uh most
important thing here is getting it out
right at the embargo which ironically i
think ends up hurting a lot of creators
because there's
like how many reviews are you clicking
on you're going to a google elgin review
you're going to click the first one
which will probably be ign game spot or
maybe some youtuber like skill up will
show up
maybe after them right and you'll watch
those and then you'll probably be bored
you'll have your uh idea about if you're
going to buy the game or not you move on
but i there's so many reviews that come
out like three or four days later that i
end up clicking on because
it's like a new video to me right right
not just lost in the sea right of the
zeitgeist
yeah and uh you know the technical issue
thing i don't know it affects me more
than most people i think because i
mainly play on pc and like
these websites don't tend to review
games on pc for some reason
and
the dying light is just a terrible
example of the way the review system
works because they broke that game
repeatedly like every patch would patch
one thing and break five more things
but because the reviews are out
everyone's moved on and no one's saying
anything about it i'll argue right now
the light 2 on pc is far worse in far
worse state than cyberpunk was wow
unplayable you're running across the
rooftops it's doing the same thing as
elden ring where it'll freeze or
textures are popping in or you'll just
fall off stuff because you're freezing
midair and the game catches up with
itself every time i talk to pc people i
get more and more scared to play stuff
on pc man i swear together i didn't
think that was there's no graphic
options they keep adding in graphics
options like the the textures in that
game no matter what you play it on or
set to like max textures so if you don't
have a ton of vram in your computer it's
going to cause stuttering it's going to
cause frame drops you have to like
literally go into your documents change
a file from like a dot scr oh no oh no
you got me doing tech work command save
like you gotta edit the files of the
game to change the texture size and
it was fine when they were updating
people they don't respond to anyone in
the steam comments at all of their posts
so they'll post be like here's a new
patch you look at the news patch they
have it pinned there's a billion
comments stuttering stuttering
stuttering stuttering and you ever
they're like no we're not gonna answer
and then on twitter they don't answer
they don't answer anywhere they've not
said what they're working on it's been
since february 16th since they've said
anything about what they're fixing with
this game but everyone's moving down to
elden ring so it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter i don't know some people
paid 100 bucks and they still can't
access
the pre-order bonuses wow
like that because you know dying light
once a weapon breaks it breaks right
there's renewable weapons you got for
buying the game like the ultimate
edition or whatever
most there's so many people who can't
even who never got to access them and
then they're like we're working on it
it's like well by the time you fix it
those weapons are going to be irrelevant
to where i'm at where you're at
yep that's correct and there's a there's
a bug where if you die it'll spawn you
outside the mission zone and then a
timer starts that will just kill you
wow hey listen
there's no way to access your old saves
because you just stuck definitely
they say they fix it and then people are
like no still affecting you and they go
email us that's great i'm not gonna
email you fix your
language i respect
that's why jimmy like when i reviewed
dying light 2 i said this is a great
game but until the issues are fixed
don't buy it yeah
but i feel like when you look at these
reviews on a lot of these outlets it's
like they don't talk about none of the
issues for these other games but some
developers and some publishers i
honestly feel like because they don't
really
they're not really scared like i feel
like if you really enjoy something like
elder ring you're a huge from software
fans you're going to ignore all that
stuff because you really love the
formula but with dying light 2 prey
stuff like that
if they don't fear any kind of
consequences to vocalizing that stuff or
you know they didn't love the game i
feel like they have no problem going 100
in yeah yeah king you've been patient
man what's your feeling on all this
reviews
let's go
so historically these souls games has
been locked to the playstation right
one of them one of the blood bombs
i'm gonna talk about the pc i don't
count the pc okay okay
so
historically these games uh for me to be
honest with you has been like you know
playstation niche type of games
and i noticed that playstation dudes
don't really criticize their own stuff
mm-hmm right so you got horizon that
comes out
and
you know
they try to throw you know
it's it's
we're not going to talk about that she's
falling through the floor
we're not going to talk about this part
and
it doesn't really impact that part when
it comes to the playstation dudes that
actually talk about it it's usually xbox
dudes which i see on my timeline
pointing out this is going wrong with
this game you buy the game to say this
is going wrong but the playstation just
kind of keep it quiet so that's why
those things go under the radar right
and yeah you guys are talking about
dying light right
dying light is a multi-platform game
they're going to rip it to shreds
they're going to rip this game to shreds
from top to bottom they really do not
care because why it's for the streets
and it's over there on that side for the
street so we're going to be back for the
streets again
and then what what what's the example on
eldon ring that's a multiple i'm gonna
get to that
and
yeah elder ring is for the streets but
i'm gonna get to
that um
but again same technical problems
you're gonna hear this vocalize more
because it's multiplied multiplied and
it's all over the place and you know
they they feel
that oh it's over there on xbox we're
gonna tear it down it's over here too
but we're gonna tear it down because
it's over there
now we come with a form software i
remember sitting inside the e3 arena
and we saw from software on xbox was
like oh big deal no it's a big deal it's
a huge deal yo cause we
xbox dudes don't want to admit it
anytime they can partake in anything
that is on a playstation platform
we rival it
yo we got what y'all got too
[Laughter]
i'm out here so hacky too don't if you
know what it is
i don't know i was like
i was hoping
yes yeah so i i get this stupid game
and i get beat up by a npc that was in
the street
and i knew for a fact they're saying
that luca this is where my frauding
comes from me this is the tr i'm gonna
show you how much of a fraud i am this
guy don't worry about it y'all got me
right now you got me bound up and tied
up
y'all y'all dudes want to get me this is
it all right all right so all right
elden ring you dudes is talk about elder
ring and y'all the expectations
was incredible and i was staunch i was
sitting there like ah shut up
y'all got me with second oh you ain't
getting me with this guy i don't care
what y'all talking about right ah shut
up that was my whole thing and even
right before it launched these things i
knew dudes that was you know playing the
game in the background yeah
even then i was like i don't care what
you're talking about
until i saw attic playing i was like
[Laughter]
that world looks white at five yeah i
didn't play sacred though and i didn't
you know i heard kids move doing that
stuff but i got it because of the game
of the year crap i remember that game of
the i got the edition upstairs i'll show
you gave me the aircraft it sold me on
it and i was like i'm in it right and
then i remember that stupid feeling that
i had when i was in the e3 arena that
was such a good game this game here
the reason why they're not talking about
the technical issues as much as possible
is because from software is usually
associated with the playstation brand
they're going to keep quiet
so that allow that loud majority that's
on twitter
want to point out the addict does not
agree
so were you playing the um what's that
were you playing the pancake version
they don't even got a full video
so
this is where the hush part comes in so
you don't gotta these guys are not gonna
say even though it's for the streets
even though it's over there right it's
associated with these dudes so they they
really the best version is played with
on the playstation platform right i
think so the playstation 4 performances
for on ps5 yeah right on the ps5 the
playstation 4 ornaments
is this the best version and they
they're like so why we ain't gonna say
nothing i would join this move over here
let them dudes complain over there right
you got to stutter and pc got stuttering
xbox xbox had that issue with the co-op
in the network for a minute too yeah
let them worry about it we good here so
a lot of the times you're not gonna hear
that loud uh cry that 97 the 97 is the
anticipation for the game
97 these dudes is like they were talking
so much before it to tear it down
afterwards after you get the review code
after you're a super fan you're not
gonna really tear down michael jackson
you was wearing a glove in the jacket
you're just not gonna do it
you had the socks on you was doing the
penny loafers you was doing this are you
applying that they capped too much early
and there's two there's no going back
from this yeah so blood on the dance
floor it was trash but you were still
capping now that's my finest he's got to
really
give
king his props for turning everything
into propaganda
okay
so now these dudes
these that's not finishing it
let's get it
the problem is
y'all dudes that follow and hit the like
35k views or or or 100k views to be
first the first eldering dude up and
people are on internet oh elder wing's
review was up let me check it if he
didn't finish it
he ain't gonna tell you that he wanted
to be the first dude out to get those
views to get these shares
that's the problem
being first is the problem not bringing
the best
not being the most efficient not being
the most complete and like jimmy said uh
uh reviewing progress is a whole lot
different when and then a complete
review right right so some dudes is like
oh i don't care about the review and
progress and bypass yours even though
yours might be a little bit more factual
a little bit more real a little bit more
detail because you're being honest but
does honesty pay right now
and that's the problem you know a dude
will hide it and i keep saying dudes
when it's everybody yeah i understand
what i'm saying you know
um
but again
it's it's the honesty part of it so
should it be some checks and balances
that hav you have to have completed it
before you can review it or submit your
review i think so
because i think
unless we have review and progress dudes
and it has to be stated that way let me
jump right in
i see carrick uh acg
put up his review of the game
i see other people put up their reviews
of the game and i can tell that acg
actually sits there and plays through
the game to its completion right or if
he if he didn't i'm pretty sure his
honest assessment of this stuff will be
forthcoming at that point so
it's really hard to just say you didn't
finish it either
i think it is hard i think when it's
tied to oh no you're paying your lights
that month it is hard yeah
look
i do i 100 with everyone when it comes
to the reviewing thing i do think we got
to pull it back a little bit in terms of
the pressure that's put on these
reviewers to get these things like kinks
sound like cognac what's this
no no but let let me finish
i think the spotlight look
we do need to have the reviews be more
transparent that's the key thing
if you didn't beat the game
it's a
shout out to
to friend of the realm maddie plays
maddie plays did he
guess what he reviewed yes he he didn't
put on i reviewed brutally honest review
he didn't do none of that stuff you know
what he put in his title he said here is
my experience of 80 hours yeah that was
gangster playing the game yeah
to me that's how you be transparent and
that title is still going to get you
clicked right yeah and here's the thing
let's jump in let's get to it
real quick oh sorry i'm sorry secondhand
yeah i think we need to focus on some of
the spotlight if not half the spotlight
because i do think they need to be more
transparent but we need to be more on
publishers and developers yeah these big
studios enough time to play these games
let's get it they're killing themselves
because that's that's where i was going
to go and i'm so glad you're on fire
with that on or something all that
because to me it's just it's a systemic
issue in the sense that
let's be real right if you're in the
game
and the publisher developer
seems to give you the game
two weeks or a month early
the consensus is oh
they feeling confident about what they
got like they feeling good like oh this
game is good
then on the opposite side
sometimes he's like yo where's the
review code at is the game going
launching today y'all next week and
where's that and then sometimes that is
synonymous with less confidence and that
let's just get it out
maybe we get the sales right and then
they can find out about other stuff
later you know so because you're not
necessarily confident in the finished
product and i think that's where the
issue is because at the end of the day
ideally you want to give everybody the
most time especially if you're an open
world you know what is it 100 plus hours
you know what i'm saying and i don't
want to be disrespectful because i know
guys you know right now that some have
put up you know 70 hours or whatever
whatever 80 hours 90 hours and that's a
lot of time i don't want to minimize
that but i'm with jimmy i'm with lucca
in the sense that
you gotta complete the game because it's
like to me that gives a more informed
position and what's happening is i think
a lot of reasons why we're not seeing
that is because the pressure to be first
right the pressure to on day and date
when the embargo is lifted
ours is up there right yeah apparently
there's websites out there that if you
don't hit this threshold of you right
clicks a month you are out of that right
and if you missed that embargo you
missed the zeitgeist you missed the
zeitgeist now you come out and yeah you
may have the completed review finished
and it's a week later but now you don't
miss the cycle and that's where the
whole thing goes so to me this is a
systemic thing it's publishers getting
reviewers the games on time to give them
the proper
context of everything you know what i'm
saying and then also the review and in
my opinion i'm a firm believer and i
tell it on logicgaming.net like i'm
always like yo
when it's done like hey man the embargo
is this i don't think some of my writers
hate i don't know if i'm gonna make it i
go
when it's done
oh i rather if you want to make embargo
review in progress or hey um semi-semi
hours in these are my impressions i
always say hey you can make an
impressions piece right you can put the
precious piece on the embargo but that's
just my rule of thumb and i understand
you know what would be a huge
impressions dude yeah i'd be an
impression finishing yeah and that's the
thing and as far and last point i'll say
as far as um you know i'll give it back
to you jimmy in reference to you know
the broker's stuff no i agree i think
look you know there is
we we got to be clear you know there are
issues from um i just think that the
review system is just a flawed system
and i think sometimes we put too much
stock in it we put too much emotionality
in it it's like oh my god this guy at
93. how could that first of all not
every reviewer reviews the same game at
each outlet so that's first then you've
got all these other issues that got to
talk about where i'm a firm believer
like i was upset a little bit in my
feelings when forza horizon didn't get
nominated for game of the year right but
i got to be clear like who's reviewing
are these going to be racing fans they
may not like races so these might be
souls fans or i call hashtag just one
fans and all they play is third person
narrative over the shoulder cinematic
experiences and those are their favorite
type of games so they're not gonna play
like put it this way jimmy i get mad i
you know when i get in my feelings every
time is the game awards and i don't see
destiny soundtrack dominated facebook oh
yeah yeah i get furious i'm like the
best on-going game oh yeah i'm like
what's going on like the best ongoing
game by far and i'm like like after a
certain amount of time they try to give
it to newer ongoing games and not one
that's like eight years old no i get
that all i'm saying is technically
there's a new expansion but it's either
in there but anyway at the end of the
day
i get what you say i get you say like
base game but at the end of the day it's
just like i i that's to me the other
flaw in the system with who is reviewing
right so to me
all this stuff is just a template i feel
you go to the people you trust go to the
people you like who you have that
relationship with or you you know they
kind of like the games that you like and
i will say this last point
i do think there is value though like
say for example if i'm a reviewer right
i am not a dark souls guy right but
let's just say it came across my play i
think there's value in my review because
it'll be like yo from the perspective of
a person who don't really like souls
games right and i think there's value to
get that feedback the same way i loved
addict's review with forza horizon 5. he
literally said in the view did i hate
racing this is a haters review of forza
and i love that because sometimes you
get that what's thank you jimmy for
helping me with that title
i remember that video because you take
you dm me right after you yes i did
great so to the algorithm jimmy but
that's all i got to say i opened it back
up to you all this is this is a fight or
we could move on whatever y'all want to
do yeah i'll just say really quick the
cycle that i keep seeing which sucks is
that
the i feel like part of the reason the
review window's so short is because
games are coming in so hot that's
primarily on the publisher's end right
like they're saying nope you can't have
any more time you got to release the
game so then the developer's like okay
we're going to work right up to the wire
here let's give the reviewers the game
when it's like
in this x amount of state like like days
gone is a great
playable
yeah and then
the publishers have no reason to change
because everyone still shows up day one
and buys these games full price when
they're 80 done good point and then sits
on them for six months they don't care
if you sit on it for six months and play
it when it's fixed because they got your
60 bucks a day already right
you don't have a refund system i don't
think on playstation you don't or like
as easy it is as it is on steam right
like
microsoft and xbox
system on playstation and xbox like as
easy as it is on steam like two hours oh
yeah yeah if you're inside a two hour
window you can get a refund you'll be
seeing games finished a lot more because
there'd be
there'd be a reason for it but people
still turn up they want to buy these
games unfinished and when you've got
reviews like i'm i'm gonna call i'm not
calling out the reviewer yeah i'm just
pointing out ign's review has the word
stutter one time in the entire thing i
search performance i search stutter
there is not a section about performance
but they have a performance video why is
that not included anywhere in the review
so the biggest review arguably is igns
they barely mention the performance the
publisher is like great everyone's going
to go and buy it anyway because they
don't know that the game doesn't work
right it's a super
it's a flawed system you know what i
actually felt just why don't you go to
lords of gaming.net
actually
i actually like people were you know
going against sony when sony did that or
we taking cyberpunk out the store i feel
like people need to be more proactive to
doing that oh your game don't work you
out of here started our storytelling
fixtures
not coming back at our store
they only did that because they don't
give you back your money it doesn't
matter why they did it though they still
did it they would rather shut it down
they give you a quarterback
all i'm saying is if a publisher had the
fear of yo we release a broken game xbox
gonna pull it steam gonna pull it
epidemic
give you back your money
and this is seat give you back your
money why because they make a money
handle with fists sony said hell no
you buy and you leave
yo and they and i swear
let five people call back they say it's
a problem with the game shut it down
because we're not giving no money back
so it's it's not an option to get a
quarterback from these dudes it's it's
either oh my god oh leave that's it
you i don't care if you made if somebody
got on your account and you call them
like nah they make that purchase so what
they will ban you lock you out of your
jewelry and you have to eat that this
nah that is the only ones that i'll tell
you i gotta buy a physical copy i gotta
go to the store i do not trust nothing
digital with these dudes but the other
guys yeah you could buy nintendo do that
too don't go over the nintendo thinking
you're going cop and your nintendo's
actually a little bit worse than sony
nintendo hang up the phone on you
[Laughter]
move it away we
told you three times we're not refunding
you i'm gonna disconnect this call cause
it's not productive anymore
check it out i got your threat
you're on the phone right and they'd be
like let me transfer you over to this
department
jimmy jimmy wrap this up they said let
me transfer this apartment incognito's
phone structure
jimmy finish this up they get messy the
the best thing about this like this you
know releasing games unfinished was i
had dine light early right two
and the stuttering wasn't there before
the game came out it was like a little
bit there but it was manageable then
they waited until the day before the
game came out when all the reviews were
out and everyone had their score up and
they were like press the button then
they go all right now we're going to add
in danube antici which
broke the game
it's caused stuttering when like a human
enemy would hit you because it needs a
trigger right right check to check the
gate making sure the game's not stolen
so they made it so when you get hit by a
human enemy it freezes for a second so
there's all sorts of shady stuff like
that going on
and no one like they just get away with
it super frustrating
yeah it's a great production when you
get hit by it
i have a video of it you can see that is
this dude official
stop for a second
we gonna register if he officially yeah
the day before the game came out and
they're like
yeah like
we'll take it out after a couple of
months it's like we'll say we knew we
were gonna punish the people who paid
you for the game
no so it doesn't get like
i don't know the logic they want to
verify if they're trying so hard
i appreciate you jimmy i don't you're
about to go in he paid to hit you like
yeah
yo move it on time you gotta be clear
before
time
great discussion of elder rig in the
industry about the critical stuff um i i
got added all the way up to
kate johnson who was a member for two
months he said he's got his ilp shirt in
the mail look johnson's a woman oh sorry
always
the lady of the realm because i always
think kevin johnson of the sons i think
kate oh i'm sorry ladies
and
gentlemen
johnson salute got her ilp
her in the mail looks amazing in person
keep rocking lawrence i'm hoping to run
into other fans of the show when i'm
wearing it one day salute get out to pax
lady k johnson because if you can with
the lords will be there come check us
out hoggy shani he had that um he had
that code in there xbox witch queen we
got that let's go to circle okay oh he
skipped me i'm done attic i need you it
skipped me out but i'm looking yeah it's
all over the place that i read because
i'm keeping it there until i read them
again yes ever born yeah let me find
everborn
you keep keep uh go ahead and say the
new um the new thing while you doing
that i'm just gonna do merch because i
didn't do um
would you call it oh hold on just to
clarify this
this is what someone is based so
so we we got he did the uh
he did the witch queen then we got
another two dollar super chat from
everborn this is how long till phil
takes val off gabe's hand
then we got a two dollar super chat uh
from having cheney giving the witch
queen uh code so definitely appreciate
that man you've been good to the realm
today then we got a two dollar super
chat from mobile gaming master race oh
my god i'm done i'm the removable gaming
master no solve huh question mark puts
choice down joystick back in pants
we got a five dollar super chat from
plate and oj give me the uh dominican
sakura
we gotta fight two dollars super chat
from splendid difference
yeah whatever
my type game i must still wait for that
game for that sale though
i feel you
then we got a final soup trap from
decade
butchered it moving past it i am
terrible at should games i don't maybe
from software games yet eldering has
been my first where i can explore and do
things on my own to help me do better at
the souls aspect wow we got a ten dollar
shooter from dawn otaku from softer uses
the same formula for 15 years and gets
praised for it while devs like ubisoft
does the same thing and gets bashed for
it still enjoying eldon rings though but
the bias for them is crazy
he has got a point there i think it's
not exactly apples to apples but he does
got a little ubisoft is for the streets
though remember what i said how many
ubisoft games that use the same formula
compared to the eight from soft games
that have released since 2009
yeah damn but anyway we got a five
dollar super
super chat from graham c acg changed his
uh
the elder ring review because of the
technical issues but too many reviewers
let things go
and too many devs are selling unfinished
games yeah definitely respect to acg for
just uh changing that because it
it that that's the kind of reviewer that
he is man like if he's like all right
they messed this up with a one patch i'm
stamping this dope until until fake
stamp on it we got one we missed hold on
we missed slo-mo slo-mo super chat he
said i'm pres i'm presently trying to
create a woman in elder ring that
doesn't look like she came out of the
hills have eyes i've not succeeded
have they ever cared about character
creation luca i don't really remember
them ever putting much thought into it
nope nope nope
then we got a 5
from flame as a reviewer myself you are
not obligated to 100 a game however you
have to complete a game where you're
just giving impressions it's disgenuous
completely agree five dollars from david
james ori we uh
did we talk about how amazing sony did
with witch queen
awesome
oh god
you might have to do that high best
thing back all right bestie that's my
man
that's not the voice that's what oh now
i gotta do the voice i gotta
[Laughter]
on the xbox series where are a lot of
the pc issues coming from all these
strong versions of the game
i'm sorry and i'm pretty sure that's it
that's it
you guys did any kind of members chat i
apologize for that i can't
pop up for attic yeah we apologize it
advanced because solves not here and
yeah because he he he copies everything
into him
oh hold on
pragmatic eagle 10 super chat
you can get it allow
you
allow me to be messy for a sec i'm still
waiting for all them i will throw my
playstation away if xyz goes to pc dudes
to throw their playstation away on
camera because we got receipts i love
iov he is hilarious but he might be on
he might be on when i bend the knee for
the gran turismo yeah you look he's
looking shaky he might be blaze by gotta
finally get a come up for you finally
y'all can go get him we'll see also i
will have that game because i think
that's that's
a game that you need to have that's like
a pivotal moment in the playstation yeah
yeah for sure and uh last thing there is
too okay i gotta get the merch gang
shout out to them or they buy you do a
lot of ilp shirts hold up hold up hold
up yeah we got a two dollar super trap
from nation oh man from nation harris uh
literally bought a c
nashon harris
literally bought a series s to play
destiny in 60 frames i appreciate you
telling me that we missed your super
chats it's easy when you guys tell me
because i could just uh control f yeah
if we yeah if we miss it just um
highlight on us oh my god they're coming
they're coming in we gotta get
yo gabe is delivering stream decks he's
santa yeah he looking like santa
super chat from lord metro breath of the
wild to his 2022 game of the year it's
just facts
we got a five dollar super chat from
scavalicious all right skate skate
letters skate lightles
imagine if last of us got a 10 out of 10
without playing the abbey missions oh
good joy good job we got to move on we
got to move on all right let's go all
right you already know what it is main
event i know a podcast found it off of
this game in name
destiny
the witch queen
sabbath dune is outside let's get to it
impressions and then also gotta shout
out my man paul tassie on the last word
podcast witty pontius with ty got
traffic it's fire it's up right now
check it out only don't check out the
end if you don't want spoilers but
i will say
paul texas spoilers
hey you can do what you got to do that's
you just as long as you give this flavor
all i will got to say he's got a spicy
article me and adam if you wanted to
spoil his bite to the end yeah
you could spoil but at that point i'll
be right back now here's the thing we've
had this discussion before a lot of
destiny fans consider a
the taken king expansion as one of the
greatest of all time and b
forsaken
as far as the great pantheon of
expansion my man paul tassie has said
he's seen enough
he's calling the fight early
in his opinion
here we go
the witch queen
is the goat expansion all
ready so let's do impressions let's
start my the queen luca
how we feeling and is that hyperbole
let's fall forward for what you played
okay you mean god's name yeah yeah god's
today
yeah listen let me tell you i uh i did
not play destiny one okay but i've
played all of destiny too
and i'm i'm with him yeah which queen is
the best
expansion
ever
uh the best expansion to date that
bungie has done
it's just like everything
it was everything i could have wanted it
had more cut scenes in it than some of
they've had for several expansions in a
row like the tinier ones and even beyond
light
from a story perspective it flipped
everything on its head in terms of the
lore
uh in terms of the loot that you get and
and honestly speaking when they first
came out and said that they're raising
the power cap to 1560 at first i was
like oh my god
really invalidated your work i i don't
feel like grinding all the way over to
1560 it's going to take forever there's
other games i want to play i'm not
trying to just be a destiny player you
know but then when they're like
legendary campaign we'll give you 15 20
gear and a new exotic i'm like all right
ben
on tuesday
i i woke up i got my workout in
took my little shower got my some lunch
and then i was chilling with the boys in
ilp yes shout out to taz i saw you sis i
was like she
is kidding oh no what's up i got in with
deaf singer and uh certain yes we were
in there from 12 p.m to 1am
did that legendary campaign
got from
50 to 15 24.
one sitting
absolutely amazing now that being said i
will say that final boss extremely
tedious
i was very i was like it's not over
another face
it was uh that was very irritating but
from a story standpoint it was
absolutely
amazing and then like that final cut
scene though spoilers
insane like absolutely insane and the
fact that some of the exotic quests at
least for the one for the uh heavy
exotics yes uh the parasite one thing
yeah
actually ties into the campaign it makes
sense
yep man listen and these exotics that we
got the us what is austria
the crafting that goes into that also
the exotics that you can choose from if
you beat all the campaign on legendary i
got the those gloves they give me uh i
got me two uh turrets oh you doing oh
yeah we picked the same gloves oh you
went stasis you go two turns no girl
okay i see you
it's absolutely amazing they did a
phenomenal job with this and this is why
i also always advocate for if a
developer is like we need to uh delay a
game yeah to continue working on it i'm
like yes delay it then
i'm happy they delayed it because this
has been
absolutely amazing i'm back i'm happy to
be back and i am enjoying my time in
destiny 2. and as she spoke to queen
spoken let's get to jimmy champagne my
man destiny but i've seen you rocking on
my when i just don't play destiny until
an hour ago yeah oh yeah jimmy's up real
jimmy's real i see him right grinding
one night i was gross like okay i see
jimmy i see his light level i see what's
going on so jimmy what's the only game
what's your light level jimmy yeah uh
right now i'm 13.05 i think i didn't do
the legendary campaign 1305.
wait 13.
what's what's the 15
1505. yeah
1505. uh yeah i did the campaign i beat
it the other night i i was blown away
and the cutscene thing i laughed because
every time there was a cut scene i was
like oh man is this the end of the
campaign and then i'd be like no there's
more this is awesome
uh i'm not gonna talk spoilers but i
liked that um
you know it's not like the end of the
campaign is being saved for the raid
right so you know it always felt
anticlimactic with all the other
expansions but this one was like a
complete story it felt really cool yeah
i loved it i agree it's it's easily the
best destiny
i actually i think i was in the minority
with beyond light i didn't realize how
much people disliked it i thought it was
pretty good but that's when i came back
to destiny oh okay so you've been away
okay i was like whoa this is this is
sweet like i looked at my this year in
destiny and it's like i got to rank like
50 in season of the hunt and then after
that you can see where i got a dick dick
because it's like 168 200 like it just
goes up and up and up
all right so now i feel like i'm finally
like in it i know how everything works i
know all the systems i know the lore and
like i'm addicted to it um
the crafting and weapon crafting yeah
that that's where i'm having a lot of
fun right now okay i like osteostreaga
i'm uh
still working on the quest for the worm
launcher thing yeah me too i gotta do it
i've got an eight of 12. okay i heard
this amazing lore with that
yeah
all the little moments in it so far i've
been like whoa this is this is like
tying into the store yes
yes and then i'm like man after i made i
made a mistake with beyonce i've been
waiting to say this that's why i'm like
going back a little bit i never really
finished beyond like because i jumped in
the season of the hunt when i started to
get to those like grindier aspects of
beyond light yeah and then going back
it's always tough so this time i'm doing
everything i can do with witch queen and
then i'll move on to risen i did the
first
uh mission so i could get that uh
story beat and then the exotic machine
gun like xenophage two or whatever yeah
and uh yeah so i don't know i'm having
so much fun with it it i'm really i'm
really just happy it's running well yes
it looks good it's got a lot of content
it's got everything you can want the one
thing the issue is those deep sight
resonance guns they don't drop yeah yeah
yeah oh jimmy
jimmy if you do that that chest glitch
itself i i when i was doing it yesterday
it's like an oh you oh we're talking
about
that
man i introduce you to some people from
friends of ours
shout out to the wilhelm screams i had
in an hour i had 15. yeah yeah yeah okay
yeah i haven't
no doubt no doubt all right so we got
jimmy's play he said yeah attic man
excellent you you are you know the dusty
connoisseur myself the crew you know i'm
saying all of us king
you know is the hype warranted
yes it is uh i feel like
the only one i could compare this to is
the taking king expansion uh i still
probably would
put that it depends on how the rate is
if the raid is just as good as oryx i
would probably put this over to the
taking king
but they gotta really hit me hard with
that raid because the radio like
because like here's the thing like
i've all i always just feel like oryx
was a more intimidating character
i feel like i feel like she got more
screen time to like really like talk her
i mean she got a whole season to build
up character for her
so but when it comes to like oryx like
like one of the biggest things i
remember playing that is just like you
know you're in that that realm with him
like not the raid but you fight him in
that little circle and he's going in and
out the epic music's playing and it's
just like i really enjoyed that now what
i do i got a little note man i got some
oh
i
i gotta appreciate the fact that they
are trying to find a better middle
ground for casual and hardcore yes
like they they they're okay look like
and it seems like they're going away
because they used to do it by difficulty
they're like look we're not going to
make too many things hard because we
want everyone to have access to it but
now they're like okay what we're going
to do is we're going to give you the
option to place something at a a lower
difficulty and we're giving you the
option to play something at a higher
difficulty and we're also going to give
you the option to if you don't want to
grind for hours upon hours to do the
right we're going to let you play this
kind of difficult legends campaign and
if you do it you'll pretty much be there
for the right you just gotta grind a
little bit yep i feel like they did that
uh i really enjoyed the crafting table
in general because that's another thing
they did to really you know if you don't
want to grind for hours and hours a lot
of hardcore people didn't want to grind
for hours and hours for perfect rolls
you know right now we're seeing the
beginning stages of this weapon uh table
i have a feeling in the next year year
and a half that table is going to have
the majority of the guns they're going
to slowly leak them back into it through
seasons through events again and you're
going to be able to really just make any
weapon you want in that thing and i
think it's little stuff like that
because i've always felt like hard
hard game
hard challenges like the raid uh trials
of osiris it needs to be more about the
skill you bring into the activity not
necessarily the
equipment that you bring in there
because the equipment should be
relatively easy to get a hold of it
should be how you take on trials of
osiris do you got good cyprus how do you
take on the raid do you know the
mechanics not necessarily yo everyone
got a gallon
that's very true let's get it king i get
a chance to really play with you
actually we talked brief we said a
couple messages briefly like yo how we
feeling what's going on yeah and he was
like yeah yeah and so what's your
experience have you have you got through
it
like what what is it is it truly meeting
your expectation
well well first go to um uh the iron
lord channel you can check out me attic
and slo-mo uh playing the game oh uh it
started off with me and actually slow-mo
no not slow-mo um
[Music]
[Laughter]
um see that's how you lean into it oh
so okay so
when we started um my expectation first
of all taking king is my all-time
favorite right
because oryx was just just
overpowering uh like like this beast
this this the boogeyman yeah right so
that was our first boogie man that we
had to overcome
and and
it was it was great stuff the fact that
his sister
usurped him
and how it's done
you know um
it's it's an incredible
journey into answering all the questions
that we had from before they answered
questions about the travel yes you know
it questioned people's religion because
remember
uh
these a lot of these dudes looked as to
travel as god mm-hmm
you wanted to go into spoilers you just
want to go into spoilers now no i'm not
i'm not oh i'm joking oh okay
yeah i was joking um i'm surprised
because you don't care i was like no no
i'm not gonna do that because this is so
fresh and so new to be honest look at
the growth
so
and i like dudes to actually play with
me pause
so i don't want to have you think that
i'm gonna spoil it for you i'm not gonna
do that um and a lot of times i mute
people in conversations and turn my mic
off just to listen to the story so i
don't jump out i just you know listen
and i'm not one of those uh dudes that
click the button and then skip it for
you after i saw it i don't need that
shout out to green mason you did that to
me oh yeah
um
but the story like like i said it
checked a lot of people's religion
because it questioned what they had
faith
it shook a lot of faith a lot of people
uh had allegiances and it questioned
alliances
they they made them question the
person's integrity yes
and it's it's different things in a
story that they used uh
and it changed how you view destiny
because a lot of times we view guardians
as omnipotent and in the people that's
in the power structure as these
unshakable uh fortified people and we
realize
in in the bottom line of this a lot of
them is just human yeah a lot of the
humanity in it is is brought into
question
and it's a lot of distrust this this
game
forces distrust because you don't
believe somebody that's talking to you
that's leading you in different
directions because
you just
witnessed the queen of lies
right the actual loki
of of of the whole yes
can we say can we give deborah wilson
her flowers though oh yes oh my god
but there's cut scenes that make you
feel for the character
you you understand it's like the same
way that you can feel for thanos and yes
good that's why i use the end game
reference yup good boy
i'm like wow they actually took the
template from disney and made you
feel for
the the antagonist
in this and are they really their
antagonists
what's what's going on here and
this gives you
a lot of answers it makes you question
what's going on everything let's talk
about the gm the
geometry oh in the engine in the
aesthetics of the world decadent that
throne world it's elegant
it's
it's looking like it's straight out of
proper rain prints and rose petals
that that start
okay yo just kidding when you get to one
part of the world right the pastel
colors i was talking about it a lot with
attic and i'm like what the hell is
going on here the hdr was tweaked to
hdr10 yeah yeah we got to call them out
on that because right they did an hdr
tweak yeah hdr like for oled guys like
myself always it's looking spooky i
don't know why it looked bad but then
other people are telling me oh my god
they fixed it so they got to find that
balance with them yeah their hdr is a
little weird better for me before on my
own me too and now look washed out a
little bit on mine
yeah yeah you have to fix it make sure
you turn off oh
motion blur go in there make sure you
check your settings because it reset all
your settings
right so you have to go in and do that
minor tweak make sure that you feel
depth of view is up i don't know why
it's not 120 but whatever
um
but then you get into different aspects
of the world you get to ones that's
egyptian in nature
um
when you get to the ships and stuff
this game is a gorgeous expansive game
right the dlc is like i said it's by far
probably one of the best so is it better
than the taking king yes
and what it's packed into it and um like
he's like jimmy champagne said the cut
scenes alone every time it got to a
cutscene i was like is this going to be
the last one yeah yeah because you used
to not get a lot from destiny like so
i'm like oh that's probably it oh yeah
no but jill knew what was the last cut
scene
when it happened yes it wasn't no
question there was no question what the
last one is but we finally got to the
left is it going to be i really want to
talk about that right
but but then like lucas said when i got
the exotic quest
this usually we've got to wait until
something else drops and then you get
exotic quest for whisper to worm or
something like that no the exotic quest
is dropped here and then you also have
this activity that's dropped here but
then you also got to go to the helm to
get another activity that's dropped here
but while we're doing that activity
there's a grinding component where you
can craft items to get exotics that you
go to this table that you do here so
it's so much to do at a different time
like get attic said this is probably the
best gaming time
for individuals especially for the last
two years to be honest with you guys
really was struggling to get to this
point and it seems like uh the gears are
starting to move forward we're starting
to elden ring uh dying light uh
forbidden west
all this stuff is
at the at the perfect time in the
beginning of the year this is still a
beginning of the first quarter you know
the content level
day one usually you get in a queue
and you gotta wait to get into the world
and i was expecting that i told my wife
we came from the store i'm like oh my
god i'm probably gonna be like three
thousand in this dagger
waiting in line at the dmv
then you get kicked out it was it was
flawless especially when they came out
and said over one million people
pre-ordered i was like oh my god i'm
going to be in this queue
you know what's funny
i was sitting there in my i was i was
laying in my bed and i was looking at it
was like 30 40 minutes to hell and then
i saw people saying oh i'm already in
the queue i got up so quick i was like
let me get in here and pop in this line
but
i wasn't cute but see the thing is i was
in queue before it came out right but
the moment the game launched i went
straight into it
i got in the house i had got my chips i
had got my water i shout out to king for
not letting me play it alone though
shout out no no no no that was not
happening um so
so and i said okay i sit in this queue
and i'm in the game
yeah this has been the easiest
because you know the third party apps
the dim stuff you usually got to wait a
day or two on a new expansion at least
and i gotta shout them out listen i have
to interrupt you because you you're on
fire with this king
this is when i know it was shout out to
forte was me forte and kai there's a boy
y'all gonna know which part i'll talk
about where you gonna have to run in a
circle and it's a mechanic and you're in
the dark and it's the most terrifying
thing that you're gonna have to deal
with for a little bit right
and
we were wiping like crazy on legendary
right right so we finally get it
the rhythm and we get the we're about to
do i mean do it or whatever or beat it
and
i got booped it was like centipede or
whatever right we all got booted
actually all of us we like oh no
right and we thought we was gonna have
to go two boards back because we did all
this other stuff to get to that point
you see what i'm saying
shout out to them because when i went to
the campaign because we're like oh if we
got to do all this again because these
this these levels of these campaigns are
long and meaty like pause but you know
like super like it is they each level of
these campaigns are um a lot so what was
so cool is each level was like the whole
old expansions like yeah yeah like it's
it's crazy amount of things how big
expensive it is and when i saw that
little kind of like the half rage circle
showing of a three quarter completed and
i'm like okay and i was like please
fingers close people
yes so
then i was nervous about having to
replay it me too because i'm thinking i
got to do the whole thing in one sitting
jimmy so i'm sitting like oh no and it
was like nope right where you the last
chest you did
three fourths of the way we're putting
you right there go back and just fight
the ball i said thank you i was like oh
my god this is a culmination of what
they've learned yes so i can see why
playstation said oh hell no
we need to have these dudes because
let's be honest a lot of games day one
don't go this smooth
if it has an online component if i if
you have to have your friends jump in
and stuff like that and the level of
upgrades to what they've done inside the
game visual
like i can put down a well on the floor
and look at the well i will ask y'all to
look at the well now it looks completely
different in certain aspects of what you
do
they've upgraded this game
to fit
the with the dlc asking price the 79
asking price for the complete package
the deluxe edition whatever it it's
actually worth that price because it
does feel like a new game
even though it's tacked on to the old
engine in the old game they upgraded as
much as they could and they gave you as
much as they could as far as content and
story-wise yeah i have to put it a
slight edge above taking king but i have
to see what this race yeah for sure
i'm gonna jump in because i hit mostly
all my points um look
to me already it is
it's not questioning about the campaign
i feel the campaign is the best destiny
campaign ever that's just where i'm at
with it right um as an expansion i'm
with addict though i'm i'm a raid guy
and i'm even though vogue is my personal
goal yes i will never disrespect taking
king and king's fall and king's fall is
a rage rate from d1 right that's the
like hardcore boss encounters mechanics
oryx is one of the most physically
intimidating bosses and presences you've
ever seen in a raid in gaming so it's
gonna be but one thing i have confidence
bungie let's be real they don't really
make whack raids these days like you
don't say so i'm at least okay yeah i'm
not worried about the quality of the
race it's just now it's going to be
mount rushmore talk we're talking this
we're talking var we're talking around
the machine we're talking last wish
that's just where that's at this point
so that's a good problem to have to this
game again we got to give devil real
sabbath dude is probably the the
greatest villain slash character they've
ever created she's way more complex than
you ever think a voice actor shout out
to her being on twitter um trolling paul
tassie doing all type of crazy like
she's all into the character like i love
it
she makes you uncomfortable
the way you know she talks to you the
cunning the deception everything about
her is amazing and they get out of here
i love that that that line at the end if
you want to play let's let's play oh
yeah yeah yeah we know about that that's
a line that's a ball for sure um
why i want to give bungie their flowers
is for all the people who always say oh
dusty doesn't have any law or no
narrative like the narrative team has
been killing it for about a year and a
half now
leading up to this point on the seasonal
content and now everything is tying
together and it makes sense and it's
almost like we said it avengers in-game
kind of feel
shoot salute to them the narrative is
crazy i want to salute the legendary
campaign another problem i've always had
with dexter you buy the new expansion
you burn through the campaign with
there's no challenge and you feel like
you know what i mean like so the fact
that they added the legendary it's the
perfect difficulty it scales depending
on the people in your fire team they
ruined their detriment yeah
they reward you at each encounter
they're giving you upgrade modules
they're giving you double chests if you
do it they're giving you a path that
okay if you challenge yourself and be
legendary right you don't have to but if
you challenge yourself if you're a light
level guy who wants to be at soft cap
and all that hard cat when you
it's giving you a path for the first
time so i think the onboarding there was
great the secrets were great the puzzles
they got mechanics and all the fights
for the most part really cool things to
do
like you know i don't want to spoil too
much it's a lot going on i want to shout
out void 3.0 game changer
love the customization making the kind
of character choosing the grenades the
super the effects the abilities like
it's to the point now where i kind of
don't even like playing with the light
other light subclasses because they're
not 3.0 like i love the fragrance okay
if i do this i get more grenadine energy
if i do this it's gonna sit the jobs
with that salute to them um shout out to
the glaive i thought it was gonna be a
gimmick y'all it was dope the glitch
yeah it's really cool it feels good with
the melee especially when you get to the
suppressing
he put me on because the suppressing
glaive
is the most like you could really op
with this thing like it's crazy what you
can do you got
absolutely crazy man and uh yeah i just
the only if i had to nitpick just
because we talking perfection at this
point um i would just say
the
i know crafting
a lot of people like it i feel the grind
for craftiness a bit much is that
and they got rng in crafting
and and the only thing is for what we're
hearing so far the enhanced version of
some of the perks
i'm not seeing from what i hear because
i don't have not seen the enhancements
yeah i'm not i'm not seeing this
tremendous
jump in you know enhance whatever like i
want to see more substantial things at
least again when i get one i'll test it
but you know look that this is mine and
stuff man this is yeah i have a
yeah i have a spear with enhanced um
you feel the difference with the
handsome
amplifier and enhance unrelenting
and um both of them are enhanced i i
guess there is like a difference it's
going to be like one of those things
like master work like there's a
difference but it's not like a huge
dramatic difference but then would you
look at that from huge it's not a huge
drastic difference like you charged me 2
000 yeah currency the currency they
charge you and aren't you hold on i got
a shout out on twitch shout out to minge
ilp clan salute he said glaive glaive
glaive clay
yo he's here twitch right now salute to
my twitch list that's what's up that's
what sounds good to see but yeah that's
all i'm going to say here glaive
but yeah they did that bungie did that
it's just i i can't even say enough now
it's just a matter of let's land the
plane
world's first raid
i'll talk to you all after y'all get the
mechanics down yeah what i'm saying
that's what's up cause that's gonna be
me nautical's like hey luca do you wanna
no day one i was like no
wait y'all waiting for contest mode to
be on first
first of all i'm not the dude to be
beating my face up against the wall
trying to figure out how we gonna do
this puzzle i don't know i don't got
nothing
i'm not struggling jimmy keep in mind
to keep in mind the people you know we
will be streaming that the eyes listen
i also want to say this we will solve i
will not be there um i i also want to
say
y'all are not going to beat the great
day one
you know all right
was only one encounter a way of beating
that rape david it was you was you
didn't do it so
so i just want to say this there's
always two one or two uh raid teams that
actually get it done right and shout out
to them for actually having the the hope
to do it y'all gonna do it but for all
you other dudes out there
acting like younger they wanted y'all
gonna knock it out y'all gonna be the
first you're gonna get the red jacket
and bungee gonna acknowledge you
they don't they have it they won't and
it's been years that y'all tried this
disappointing okay you don't need to
y'all need to submit baby
right now y'all could say this is one
thing y'all could say we gonna go in
there and test the waters to see what it
smell like y'all could do that that's
nice right we want to see the new
content yay right but what me and luke
are gonna do
is uh wait for y'all to bloody yourself
all the mechanics and then the
difficulty is there hospital after i get
out the hospital y'all holler at me and
luca and y'all be like okay so this is
the part where okay i want you over here
to grab the ball
and put it in the basket oh he's savage
but wait till y'all hear the queue to
grab the instructions you with the
premium experience
but
now
y'all better shut up
and all you dudes uh you know i'll i'll
see your stuff later if we beat that we
could never take off
if we beat that i would i might wear the
rage
[Laughter]
i will say that after um they put in
the con was a contest modifier yes you
know team redeem has not been world's
first since then yeah so it's more
exciting
and i think the last
last raid it was a completely unknown
team that ended up winning yes that's
because that makes it more even luca's
trolling the hell out of you
luka just wants to build content to
watch she getting her popcorn ready and
it upset a lot of the people on those
those big right teams like i remember
even um
who was it what a big a big destiny
youtuber got mad because of it like
claude
yeah glad remember glad got a little
upset because he felt like he was
casualized a lot yeah he said like oh
it's like anyone can do it now or
whatever like whatever he had said he he
claimed that that wasn't his intention
and he ended up having to apologize the
thing of it is it's like it's their job
to play this game they they get paid
through their streams because they're
twitch users and youtubers right and
they can have the time to spend 20 plus
hours on this game while other people
don't like other people have different
kinds of jobs so it's like they bungee
made it fair for everyone and it's like
it's still fair like they could still do
it but the main reason they were winning
is not only because they had the time
and you know the pers perseverance
endurance like the strategies but a lot
of it was they were able to power level
faster yes yeah
yeah and then you got to look at it like
i think a lot of the reason that you
might even just glide like a lot of
those uh destiny youtubers are getting a
little upset because it really took like
the spotlight off them in terms of like
the best destiny players like they are
the best destiny players but now it's
just like now since other people could
participate it's letting more people in
that club that i'm not part of
think i actually think other people were
already in that club but because they
didn't have channels no one knew about
them well that's what i'm saying is let
other people get the opportunity
me personally i feel that that's the
rays are the greatest one of the
greatest content in gaming and from a
cooperative experience i i've some of
the most fun i've had in rn raids and
it's a shame that when you looked at the
numbers prior to the last two raids the
numbers were not high as far as
engagement so i have no problem with
them saying yo let's do contest mode and
you know let's get more people in so
everyone is at the same level no matter
how much higher you get than what is it
15 30 you're going to be the same level
coming in and it gives more people a
chance to play and compete because
ultimately it comes down to the
mechanics teamwork and not you know
having the frustration so i like that
personally you know i'm saying so i
don't i don't have luca yeah they might
do it this time yeah they're gonna and
they they see it it's the best content i
believe in them yes
you know what i'm a tune in too yeah
you're ridiculous anyway all i always
say is they look forward to it it's
going to be a moment
it's going to be a day
jimmy jimmy real quick before we move on
um
will you be day one rating or will you
be waiting
uh what the hell dude when does it come
out march 5th saturday saturday i'll be
uh today in the pacific i'm celebrating
my birthday that day oh
happy early birthday happy early
birthday happy early birthday
no i would not be frustrating my
birthday
he's like you ain't doing that you put
that away and salute no i do want bungie
do one thing if they can we know contest
mode last and jimmy and king and and
lucas she could come in after the fact
when it's disabled but i would like them
to have it as an option post world first
so that if people want to try it
yeah they could have a contest
and get good rewards for so shout out to
tags like if that had contest mode for
him and say like you almost guaranteed a
vex so you ain't got to run it it's a
good time i still didn't get my victims
yeah i ran i ran it 56 times before i
got my vaccine oh you guys
and as soon as he got back he
disappeared i was like hello don't judge
me this dude here man shout out to the
the pc dude that came back to find out
what's funny
what what call just well cog does like
multiple raids back to back he's like
man you guys got me out here doing all
these raids
but when he was trying to grind for that
backs he said yo you want to do it again
like you know look we got to get the
peoples i got to play along and i know
we had king i know we had the other two
towers but i gotta get my people out
first you want to still do those little
quick ones but i gotta respect what i'm
doing but okay i don't think they want
to be part of that so so look i know if
you got to go sis let me know to find
people where they can find you that scum
cast
thank you guys so much for having me i
had a lot of fun discussing these topics
it was a great time with the boys you
already know
uh you guys can find me on twitter at
the ash and lucca i also have a podcast
called scumcast that is every saturday
at 6 00 p.m central time which is 7 p.m
eastern and yeah thanks so much for
having me no doubt you already know says
look i'm putting the information in the
chat this is the homie
the action luca that's a twitter go
subscribe to the channel she's iop
approved iop approved she's been fan
from day one rocking with us
what's funny is she gets to witness when
uh she's in the chat right she joins in
and everybody's talking yo yeah you know
you know then luca jones and they're
like well hello oh yeah yeah they
reactionary they reaction with lucas
oh who's that
i said if you don't stop shooting your
damn shot and worrying about the rain
luke is like one of the only people i
know
that like the real messy people that
they they won't even mess with lucas oh
no no did you find out very quickly what
it is
always love says thank you for dropping
it you already know jimmy i don't know
if you're rocking not that i'm kicking
jimmy out jimmy can rock too but i just
want to be you gonna like this next i
want to be cognizant because we got
fallout new vegas and uh what you call
it um it was nice meeting you jimmy you
guys yeah nice to meet you all right
cool jimmy how are you doing on time i
just want to be clear oh i'm good okay
cool so jimmy's rocking all right so
cool jimmy liked the message
all right that's what's up so um yo cw
stopping cw hey lucas stop see that's
the behavior that we're talking about
don't be hey luca and
cw i see you leave sister i'm just
joking
oh jokes inside cake we'll combine this
right now um but the first part is
actually addicts which is um fallout new
vegas um obsidian
rumors uh shout out to jez corden and
windows central shout out to october and
windows central and shout out there
actually it was jeff grubb the grub
snacks we had grabbed one before um so
yeah it looks like new vegas development
i'm going to write a book one day on how
much he he's leaked the industry
shout out jeff grover's leaked industry
obsidian entertainment and bethesda were
quiet but um yeah the rumors are that
you know they're developing could be uh
by obsidian and published by bethesda so
that was new vegas one but it's
reportedly in early talks new vegas too
the potential sequel if it's
materializing maybe a year away but um
yeah shout out to grubb this is going on
there addict this is your top i'll let
you set it off this is a revered game
right what are we thinking yeah a lot of
fallout i don't jimmy are you a fallout
fan i'm a huge fallout okay so what what
is your favorite fallout game uh
definitely three no
so it's either new vegas or three yeah
usually the vegas uh the the fallout
community split between those two
uh you know how i am with this is like
i'm really i love new vegas and i think
the reason i love new vegas more than
three just because of like the aimed out
sights and stuff like that in the
faction system that's just a natural
progression of the franchise and not
necessarily like exclusive to fallout
new vegas but they did have a really
good world as well like you know with mr
house the nrc the uh the legion but you
know a lot of people
never thought that a realm could ever
exist where fallout comes back call it
new vegas
and for the most part we never see a
fallout in the same region twice
so it would be interesting if we do see
a fallout of new vegas too because if
they do do like 10 15 years afterwards
we can see the progression of the
choices that was made in the original
fallout new vegas and that's where i'm
at with this like i do have some caveats
i don't want this to happen if
obsidian's not making it and i don't
want
and i don't want i'm not the kind of
person to like try to force the studio
to making it so if like obsidian doesn't
want like if there's people over there
that want to take a team and make it
make it like you know hire outside and
make uh follow new vegas i'm 100 for
that okay but if it's going to take away
from a vowel or you know whatever they
do after about i would prefer them to
keep this where it's at which is no way
question before we uh because yeah yeah
i'll get a question for you before we
open it up to jimmy um
so
obsidian made
new vegas
yes and
has made a lot of stuff they made south
park stick a troop
yeah i was just all i was gonna say was
just that um
you know with this information
do you think because we've never seen in
a fallout game
a direct sequel usually it's like okay
we're in philadelphia this year we're in
whatever it is right
here
so
do you think if this the rumors are true
which they see you know grab track right
has been good that there is another
fallout game do you think it is in new
vegas too or do you think that bethesda
would say okay
we'll give them the rights to make the
next fallout
as opposed i was curious i didn't get
considering
okay jeff grubbs usually pretty good at
selecting his words
i feel like if they were out there
seeing a new fallout game jeff grubb
would have set a new fallout game i i
feel like that's different from the fall
at new vegas 2. like that's a specific
fallout game not like a sequel or
anything like that maybe you know
bethesda because there's always that
i know bethesda don't like the fact that
a lot of people feel like their best
fallout game was made by another company
so maybe bethesda was considering making
a fallout new vegas to to to like to to
like be like yeah we made that not then
so you know but then again it's like you
know maybe they took over that project i
don't know but all i do know is you know
i actually said multiple times on this
podcast that i think obsidian should be
handed fallout i've said multiple times
on this podcast but i don't want it to
take away from what they're doing
because i personally feel like they have
earned the right to make what they want
to make for sure to be pushed about made
on something but who knows maybe
obsidian wants to make maybe
okay and maybe once they bought that
studio
that uh once they got hands on the
fallout franchise maybe there was a
conversation like obsidian you have
experience in making quality because i
said maybe exile entertainment could
make it too mm-hmm if you want to make
wasteland yeah but it's like maybe since
they since they have experience making
fallout maybe that conversation was
happening it's like look like
we because i i'm with maddie like i
don't think that you know we need to
focus on fallout over something like
elder scrolls but i don't think we need
to to keep fallout after elder scrolls
because we're damn near waiting a
generation for that game yeah like
almost the entire generation and maybe
half the next generation it would take
to have a new fallout i feel like that's
unacceptable i agree i agree
someone else needs to take ownership of
the fallout franchise to give us a game
sooner rather than later and if it
i only see obsidian i'm going to be real
now if they want to take like some
studio heads that deserve an opportunity
to lead a team let them make another
team and let them make fallout but if
it's going to take away from a valve
that's where i draw the line don't do it
no i think i i i think it'd be fine but
i hear what you say i agree it can't it
can't take away from other projects
jimmy you are a fallout connoisseur
yes when you hear this news vegas 2
obsidian bethesda may be handing the
reigns potentially in talks what are
your what's your thought process
i think that's a good idea for like
the franchise right to give people more
of the one that they always say is the
best their favorite i like that
i'm more into the exploration and combat
side of fallout i had a lot of fun with
fallout 4 you know just exploring that
world i really actually
did end up liking the settlement system
after i installed this mod that like
makes it so they run themselves
basically it's called like sim
settlements right it's fun so i'm more
into that aspect of it and i think
new vegas is kind of it's not bad there
it's just a little bit weaker than three
and four in my opinion
um so like i think as a brand i think
that's the smartest move they can make
right like let obsidian work on that
while they're working on uh star field
right
sticks you get this like right here
because we're talking like eight years
jimmy's gonna take a while
some of that reputation from seventy six
yeah seems like 76 is moving to life
support right now it seems like the
right time right
yeah it's cool but i don't know i hope
that
they at least get some help from
bethesda on making a cool map to explore
because that's that was my favorite part
of four was you know digging through the
comic shop and finding the axe
there's so many
like where the story falters them for
the locations and some of the like
dungeons quote unquote were just so cool
and had really good environmental
storytelling so if they can get that
then there you go you know jimmy the
good thing about fallout is i feel like
if obsidian does take over the reigns of
fallout
it's different from fallout new vegas
and the reason i say that is because
fallout new vegas they was contracted to
make it so it's kind of like
bethesda and then we're not on equal
playing terms but if they make a fallout
new vegas i feel like bethesda and i
mean who knows maybe the the way that
that fall in new vegas is being made is
co-developing bethesda and obsidian are
going to have smaller teams together
that come together to make that one game
yeah that'd be cool i i'm just thinking
like they would need that because i like
the outer worlds but the outer world
feels a lot like new vegas where you
know the conversations the quest lines
being able to be figured out just by
talking yeah you know like all of that
was definitely the focus in outer worlds
the weakest aspect of that game is the
exploration to me like
yeah the combat too the combat doesn't
really feel that good there's no
real reason to go out of your way and
explore some of the bigger maps you know
you can find your requests new
conversations new characters but like
i'm more in it for the actual like game
which is the combat combats me okay
so that's why i want them to get the
help but like microsoft's huge now right
like they got a bunch of studios
they can figure it out they can get a
team that can work on the combat to help
them out i think uh but yeah i i'm just
not i don't i like rpgs i'm not the
biggest like
quest line oh done with talking rpg got
you you jimmy will shoot stuff he won't
get his murder this is jimmy hacking
slash jimmy okay i got you that's where
me and you are different because that's
25 seconds okay well i got you five
seconds on that um yeah no i i hear you
i mean
you know it's some some interesting
points i i totally understand i can see
why you like a fallout 4 you know i'm
saying a little bit more with the action
aspect and stuff like that and let's be
real you know one thing i have to give
you even though i'm team obsidian all
day but i have to give you that you know
i like vats i think vats is such a cool
system targeting the leg target arm all
that good stuff like bloody mess yeah
like i love that stuff you don't see it
and i'm just it's just cool i mean if
king took a while i'll just jump my
points on it
i'm excited because this is something
i didn't know what happened because this
is how i looked at it obsidian was part
of that early draft class in my opinion
with microsoft acquisitions right and in
my mind obsidian to me is like little
bro who feels that just as good if not
better than big bro beating bethesda
that went away yeah right
so the way i look at it it's like yo we
gonna make but i'm just i'm just making
them i'm not saying that i'm sitting
there saying any of this this is
cognito's thoughts of acting like this
is like a sports team and like in my
mind they're like yo we could make our
own better version of skyrim with a vow
we could make our own little kind of a
fallout e kind of thing without the
worlds right and have our spin have our
humor and rpg stuff and
on one aspect i get it but at the same
aspect you know new vegas is revered
right and there's a fallout game and
this is where i agree with you jimmy
to me
because of the success of elder scrolls
we know that's coming later in the gen
and we know star feel and let's just be
real let's say star field hits
and it's a mega success they got
starfield to manage they're gonna want
him
it's already so now fall out and let's
be real jimmy's on fire with this like
they're coming off 76 which is not a
mainline fallout game but the the brand
kind of tarnished and then you're gonna
go a whole console generation with no
fallout game and rest in peace maddie
played because that kills maddie's soul
he loves
yeah you're like how you gonna go whole
gen without a fallout game so to me this
is the perfect thing and i like the idea
of big bro and little bro talking
because now that they're in the same
house living in the house of microsoft
maybe relationships is better over the
years and now it could be a situation
where it's like okay look we'll give you
some people you know to help with the
code development or whatever whatever
and to the people who are where i'm with
attic though it cannot take away from
obsidian's projects right it cannot we
know that they got four or five things
going on a lot and it's going to
probably be a while for development
anyway but as long as it's in the
natural flow after a vowel or whatever
i'm for it and i think the city would be
the perfect people to do it they got the
experience they have the their
reputation
yeah you know what microsoft's too right
yeah they're working on that you know
what microsoft might be doing behind
closed doors
that's like we know
bethesda's has too much on their plates
we don't know who to give this to right
let's see how they handle a sequel to
their own game and they hit that out of
the park
then we'll give them the fallout
franchise for them to make on their own
yeah it could be it could be that i just
like that they're talking i'm gonna be
honest because in my mind i'm not saying
it's beef
but if bye bye it's big bro little bro
and i feel little bro always had to chip
for the shoulder yeah so to see that to
see bethesda even whoever got them in
the room whether it be as king would say
phil dominance maximum but like i got to
make a fool out there i don't know who's
who got them
oh sarah about whoever got there the
wrong king is the perfect transition to
you like what are you thinking with this
whole situation
who did fall out new vegas obsidian
obsidian right
i figured that that was the best one
okay
right
so it's the best one you know but
bethesda and obsidian's under the same
household doesn't even matter
you know um the game is going to be made
you know because there's too many uh
people crying for the game to be made um
and the fact that obsidian is linked to
it gives you a level of assurance
towards it um i i don't i don't care
in what space it comes in because
um as far as
uh does it take away from a vowel i
don't think anything will take away from
anything i think they have so many
moving parts
as far as developers and stuff go they
can pulling yank people from certain
projects to help in on this and helping
on that being that they are so
intertwined right now and they are
lending technologies uh uh from uh
studio houses across the board so
i don't think it takes away from
anything uh schedule wise
i think that's where the problem comes
in where does it fall in yes as far as
what we're going to drop schedule wise
because you don't want uh
like too many games of the same uh feel
or genre it's definitely gonna be games
delayed because yeah there's definitely
gonna be games delayed so i i think that
it's
however the cadence goes
i think the game is gonna be fantastic
anyway because they are all under the
same roof so they can lend technologies
lend thoughts and we know that that that
script for that game already has been
done they probably passed it off to him
and said hey how can you work this up
and how can you fix this up oh we we did
have a proposal for this done let's
check this out and go over things so
yeah no i have no fear in that game i
think that game is gonna be uh fantastic
when it does come out um it's just about
the cadence so when they're gonna drop
it but i want obsidian to do it i don't
want um anything else anyone else to do
it right that lends a level of um
how i uh how can i say it like
confidence in the title yeah being drawn
yep if anybody's gonna do it to me
that's the perfect choice
so we'll see what happens and then
hopefully matty be happy and he won't
miss a fall out for this year
so that's what i got but we'll move on
this is the bonus round this is king's
last one and we get up out of here and
i'll just add it right now um
steam steamed that no it wasn't that one
i wasn't that one of the duty oh you
still wanted that oh okay i didn't care
about that this thing oh so you don't
care about steamed ducks okay on the
door i'll be back all right cool we're
talking about all right so uh cod i'll
just freestyle off the top didn't this
is in reference to um the whole
situation right now that we're hearing
that cod is no longer going to be
annualized right and that
and that um you know apparently this is
beforehand you know of of the
acquisition closing at microsoft you
know king i'll give it to you you've got
a lot to say here clearly you wanted to
talk about this so let's get ready yeah
he's ready yeah what's up so so it seems
that call of duty might go missing for a
while uh-huh
where are we going with this and how
does this affect your playstation i want
to hear this listen to this i'm just
saying maybe contracts run out games
maybe when stuff is finalized and done
you done
so you implied that there could be a
potential because it's now gonna miss a
year
that
we're conscious so you say that this
could be something that where the uh
playstation contracts for marketing and
all that won't have to be respected and
are we still holding on to the fact that
there will not be a multi-player
situation that this will be this
multiplayer's called warzone
[Laughter]
it's called
get your wall zone
get your skins get up in there you don't
have fun with that you got war zone god
bless good luck so let's see now that we
find out that you're joining coming out
this year
next year it might it might slide past
next year 2024 looks like the opportune
time after deals is signed you know
y'all got all your war zone in and
everything got good y'all great um
you're gonna turn the faucet off yeah
and make the cut yo and make the
comeback and it's exclusive
so sir king you do realize they're under
regulation right you do realize that
they have already said that they're in
the regulation you're not a director but
they have come out and said that they it
takes night the police is looking at him
the police ain't looking at me
so they have to play nice you know right
now they under sanctioned me be looking
they checking to making sure they're not
fighting and doing them crazy
but as soon as those eyes is awesome
and that's where you feel they're gonna
they're gonna pull call of duty from
playstation okay as soon as the teacher
leave the room the bully gets busy
moving on
jimmy king is messy oh i was like why
does he want to talk that would make
sense
okay now it makes sense so let's get it
to jimmy what what is your feeling about
call of duty missing which is a big
king's defense it is a big deal i cannot
not minimize that like call of duty is
one of the biggest highest grossing
games to not make you know every year is
a big thing so what do you feel about
that in reference to quality game and
kings theory
uh i think it's good obviously because
the last few years of call of duty it
felt like you know they're like flying
down the highway with parts falling off
like this this year in particular though
i was seeing a lot of pushback uh
ironically on tick tock people were just
like shredding them for
you know like guns having sights from
2020 in them on these like world war ii
guns yeah extreme graphics issues just
like
it wasn't ready and then same thing with
call of duty black ops cold war there's
a lot of messy stuff in there and i
don't think if they really can afford to
have a situation again like they had
with black ops 4 where they're just
putting out multiplayer that was a mess
yeah i feel like regardless of the
microsoft purchase they probably realize
like yeah we got to take a step back
here really recalibrate see what's going
on with the franchise and like find a
new path forward that
is releasing a complete game because
call of duty is the biggest game in the
industry right you want to have a stamp
of quality on there
and when you've got it like falling
apart
it's not great also they're probably
looking at battlefield like yeah
like battlefield
felt like too big to fail and it failed
yeah so
like we're just probably saying like
okay you know like
we can lose this you know they're
probably
not feeling as confident as they are
that they can throw anything with the
call of duty name on it out there and
people will play it because you know i'm
sure they kind of felt that way a little
bit of war zone but warzone's a good
playing game yeah it was always like
this before like when it came out it was
great for multiplayer like solid all the
way through like they've admitted
they've screwed it up as more patches
come out and stuff but
i think they know what they're doing
they just need more time to do it and
yeah i like that activision of all the
companies is the one saying okay we're
gonna
give it the time it needs isn't it kind
of weird like after the bag is in the
situation yeah it is
do you believe that there
even though the acquisition is not
complete
that this would have happened
if the acquisition wasn't happening or
do you think like because there's a
rumor that maybe they're more emboldened
now that
bobby and those guys that microsoft owns
them that they can afford to do this now
or do you think this is already in the
plans regardless i'm not a businessman
right yeah i don't really know how any
of this works i don't think a lot of the
people reporting on it know how this
works but
they have a shield now right they have a
buffer between them and the shareholders
that are probably
like the annual release you know they
can say look like
we're giving the whole thing to
microsoft anyway let's let's make a
quality product this time just see how
it goes right like stuff's in in limbo
and most of those people are going to
make their money at the end of the day
because
microsoft's literally buying the shares
yeah and they're buying them for a lot
of money so like the shareholders are
probably like yeah dude do whatever this
year we're just waiting until what is it
june 2023 when we make all of our money
like they're just sitting there
kicking
do whatever you want just don't take the
company
no fair enough i'll jump in you know
this was interesting i'll be honest
call of duty is so
huge
that in my opinion i'm like damn like
you feel like it's never gonna you know
stop being made and they're never gonna
take a break and it's like even when
microsoft acquired and i'm just like can
they really walk away from that annual
money that it makes right because even
in its worst
iteration what was it vegas like
technically there's worse they got a
scandal in the building the game
quality's not good and they still number
one by far now granted it's not number
one comparison to other call of duty
number one levels but number one in
comparison to the rest of the games
industry so
that's why i looked at i'm like nah
corporate ballroom going over they're
going to like still pump it out
and to you know to the credit i like
this man give it time to breathe you got
war zone outside you know which is
taking off they to me
i i'm not even a battle royal guy like
that
yeah it actually is for the streets
i know what you're doing but um at the
end of the day
you know
[Laughter]
jigsaw or billy the puppet yeah there
you go
it's the jimmy game right there ghost
face like there it is but i love the
fact it's gonna
it's gonna take time for development and
that makes it a better game when you
have that two the extra year cycle you
get more quality and um
yeah it is interesting i'm gonna be
honest i i'm gonna speculate i don't
have any inside information but i
i feel that if
the former ceo was still there
i don't know if that's happening this
break thing because to me the philosophy
has been call of duty all you studios
are gonna work on call of duty and every
year if we're gonna rotate the studios
with three different studios it's coming
out and maybe they're more emboldened
you know saying kick while adding
laughing right why i gotta did that that
was that's addictive oh addy got the
demonic laughs
but
i'll i'll wait for my turn okay he's
going so yeah that's it i mean we'll see
what happens it'll be interesting to see
king's theory or not but attic you up
what you got call of duty no
annualization
taking taking a break but yeah
i feel like
this was okay i have two different
perspectives that this could have
happened here one
the game needed to be delayed but they
were going to push it out anyway but now
they feel like at that time they'll be
owned by microsoft
and
they probably
consulted with microsoft under the
download because they're not supposed to
do it
it was like should they push this in
crunch and
and i think in the back of mind it feels
like well since i'm going to be forced
to release call of duty on
don't care if it comes out next year or
not so
make sure it's the best call of duty you
could possibly make
and let's get that out when the call of
duties need to come out and not
necessarily because they have to come
out
you know it's a lot of money to to to go
away it is and
but i don't know if
phil is more focused on the money that
call of duty can bring in or the talent
that having college do not come every
year can free up yeah and jimmy i'm
sorry i'm sorry so that's that's that's
all i got for you all i gotta say is
jimmy made a good point too in the sense
that
we gotta we gotta be real you know
battlefield scares a lot of people what
happened to battlefield 2042 still did
that today we know
yeah addicting like the stitcher addict
was like last week he's like yo stop
blaming other people
oh you're good
it's right it's like stop bringing up
yeah
put your arm back on put your helmet on
and walk across the street and handle
your business don't blame everyone else
he'll be bringing up with some kind of
you know people like
they just brought halo up in a
conversation why would you bring up any
brand in another conversation another
brand
that was a hot bike no one was supposed
to do about that company man
they snitching they out here with the
six nine faces don't do that don't bring
them up in there you should have been in
game pass you you bet on yourself or you
lost so look at that
but at the end of the day look you know
i think it scared a lot of people and
and kudos to call of duty for whatever
reason for doing it so that's all i got
we gotta give you super chat then we
gotta get about yeah let's get these
students you guys are just steamed
xbox steam that gets your game talking
games outside game say they want to work
so
attic i'm gonna need help
there's a lot yeah
and what's messed up is i couldn't help
but i pressed the button and it thank
you for your contribution thank you for
your contribution thank you
thank you
thank you for moving forward
while adding ready i will do the poll
thing which i think would like forget
about it all right so new iop poll
pertaining to review scores for highly
anticipated games how much should bugs
glitches or performance issues
influence the final score the choices
are a a studio's past pedigree should
not influence the review if the latest
iteration is riddled with bugs or
performance issues
b
if the gameplay fun factor are master
class or high-end in the genre then some
bugs should not [ __ ] the score or c
i don't care y'all just bad because they
reviewed your favorite game with a lower
metacritic score than the ops
to everybody in the iop
chat and clan it will be up on the
logicgaming.net twitter account and the
online podcast twitter account check
that out again salute first of all we
got to salute the amazing
resolution games we would play demeo we
would play that they gave us bars man a
lot of stuff pc steam demo out right now
go wish list that go check it out
he gave us a lot of premium bars i'm
gonna put that in the chat again if
you're not a vr it's out on vr right now
on our mediquest vr as well as steamvr
but if you're not a vr person you can
get the pancake version that we learned
that the dads call it that they agree
with king they call it the pancake
version what i was just joking out here
playing around man tell you the pancakes
listen it's outside steve go check that
out it is crazy and that flame says c is
already with it so your flame is messy
but um yeah go check it out and support
them salute to gustav stanmark the
entire resolution game studio on that
attic are you ready for super yeah all
right before we got a five dollar
shipping drive from dollar taco before
you start before you start i got it i
got to give the asha luca her flowers
salute the lady luca for pulling up
salute scrub cast goes to lugo support
and of course the legendary hack and
slash legend lsm family brother my man
jimmy champagne that i met in one of the
coolest so what's it like a cigar bar
that ball was fire yeah i was thinking
about that the other day i was like that
was so cool that was so cool man yeah
shout out to somebody you were just
chopping it up with yours
something's not here yes oh yeah saul
had to work he wanted to be here you
know what i'm saying so salute to you
man brother i love what you're doing uh
salute to the child ps ready right p.s
ready you know what i'm saying yes and i
just started deck ready the steam deck
channel oh
yeah
like how you feel about uh
gabe talk about he would be open to
putting game pass on the deck and you
know making that happen how you feel
about that
that's cool because then all these
people keep talking about gamepads
we'll just stop talking about it
steam is so cheap now like
you can get you can if you can't get a
game full price you can wait a couple
months for the summer sale the fall sale
the easter sale there's like a sale for
tuesday i feel like
you get the game so cheap where you kind
of gotta weigh it against 15 a month
versus just owning the game on your
steam account i don't know i've noticed
that the steam deck community
real talk the way that they feel is
they want to just play on steam os yeah
and
the it was pretty disappointing to see
how many of the steam deck reviews were
like
hinging almost entirely on the fact that
they couldn't install windows and use
that really you're not even using them
all yeah they're like they're like it
would be easier to test stuff like kind
of but it's not going to run games the
same
you know you're playing a console at the
end of the day it's like supposed to
bridge the gap between pc and console
like let the the os that they spent all
this time designing
do the talk uh but i'm excited i wish
they would just release the ls so i can
yeah
but people are loving it people are
raving i can't wait i'm in q2
unfortunately so i'm not one of the
lucky ones like you but yeah it's as
avatar i'm q1 i'm q1 but i think i'm
gonna end up
splurging and just getting someone's
pre-order off ebay or something
just because i have the channel now
because i want to have one in my hands
we 3d printed one we took the cad files
and 3d printed like a dummy unit okay so
that i did like how it feels with the
hand review honestly dude it feels like
really good like immediately uh people
are talking about with the switch the
satisfy grip this goal i love that i
guess it feels very similar to that and
i was really worried about those back
pedals being
hit okay they aren't so absolutely
no doubt and where else they got you
where else people can find it you gotta
put your twitter account put the jimmy
champagne youtube channel you still
that's that's my horror channel yes
that's the whole retro if you like if
you like halloween mm-hmm michael myers
stuff yeah he's down for all of that
yeah no doubt man for you pulling up
thank you man good to always get you
outside it was exciting yesterday i was
like yes yeah man there we go we're
gonna talk we got all the stuff we want
to do with you man yeah salute to jimmy
champagne the legendary let's get that
attic you've been patient let's get
these super chats respect the realm
let's get this five dollar super chat
from daughter taku all y'all
uh all y'all eldon ring horizon and god
of war ragnarok cap cappers out there
you can dread it run from it okay breath
of the wild two will be
20 22 game of the year all the same
talking about that you got donna taku
with a two dollar super chat
star phil can catch that smoke too
and then you got five dollar super trap
from black rodent three five seven let's
talk about honoring having some of the
worst customization for black people
ever it's like um uh uh it's like
african
uh descent does not exist in the game
lore
yeah gotta work on it we gotta do better
we gotta do better for character
creators agreed
then we got a two dollar street return
from east texas alex
i don't know he got a call to my
playstation brother yeah he put a call
he put a quote in for playstation
brothers i salute east texas for giving
up codes absolute and then we got
another one from him putting up another
card oh brother that's love next time
people put code uh you know try try to
put what it is before it too so i i can
you know yeah without forgiving that
game though for sure so we gotta find
out scripture from dragon heart yo tv
well let's yobe tv
realm let's crowd astronaut luca as the
queen of iop for today hashtag iop x z
that's
then we got a ten dollar super chat from
dodotaku i don't want obsidian making
fallout
they i like them focusing on their own
ip like a valid wasteland wasteland
isn't made by them okay which is their
fallout
uh what they could be into an fps
uh that actually um obsidian uh the
people who make waistlines uh is exile
entertainment yeah uh so we got five
dollar superchat from donald trump why
did i say wasteland i'm mixing up exile
they have outer worlds so they don't
need fallout daughter talker i think i
agree with you only if they don't want
to make fall up but if they want to make
fallout
let them make fallout that's just my
opinion respect respect doubly rate with
the two dollar super chat are the ps
card deals tied to the games themselves
um
gonna be interesting a lot of
information we gonna find out
we gonna no so we are caught up and then
again shout out to the realm everybody
you know i got the merch and all that
good stuff um yeah man let's get up out
of here
talk to people where can they find you
what's going on
follow me on twitter lord addict iop you
can also find me on twitch i might
stream on twitch today because uh dj
harassing me to uh harassing us to raise
yeah
i might as well stream that if we're
going to jimmy what's up we gotta we
gotta get in some destiny with you too
when we talk about that but yeah
tomorrow at 5 00 pm i will be streaming
eldon ring again on the twitch channel
so i'll come
around and look for that hopefully i can
get to the next boss i beat the first
boss it took me like 45 minutes but got
through him you can find me on
tuesday at 5 00 p.m on the attic show
with uh my co-host hustle motivate i'm
sure we're going to have a pretty uh
inlightful conversation this week
because a lot of stuff's happening this
week apologize for missing last week but
i had that case of destiny itis so i had
to cancel
you magically got sick on uh launch day
sir i appreciate your guys's concern for
my well-being i'm okay now oh you're
okay now okay
but yeah i appreciate everyone coming by
man no doubt you already know lord king
we're gonna find people finding what you
got going on sir first of all i want to
thank gustav from coming through um it
was fantastic stuff uh demio is
great i can't wait to check out the the
lounge area yeah uh
everybody's talking about this is
it sounds fantastic it sounds uh
phenomenal i can't wait for uh you guys
to um you know sign that contract with
the playstation vr
i think that's going to be lit
uh ashton luca shout out to you that's
that's she that's that's my ray girl we
out there you know uh most of the time
when i'm doing raids
me and luke is there it's really crazy
so uh shout out to her scumcast and the
squad uh check out on saturdays
and my man jimmy champagne
the king of horror yes um check out his
stuff this dude is impeccable
um i wish i was there with the cigar day
i wasn't i don't smoke
i'd have definitely been in there with a
fan you know fanning people away
get out of here with that get that out
of my lungs
but uh yo check out jimmy champagne and
yeah of course uh destiny we can hook up
eight scrolls play so if you're
stuttering a little bit don't worry
about it i got you stuttering
yo
[Applause]
you guys could catch me on elden ring
this week
actually um probably streaming that oh
no because the fact that they they did
the update and you actually just hit a
button and you could just stream
um that's for some guys never seen me
stream can you stream it
yeah these dudes been asking you ain't
gonna catch me on the camera because i
have the time i'm butt naked
[Music]
no i actually have on shorts um but
i'm in my house who cares i probably
don't judge me i'm not gonna throw an
arcade cabinet outside of my shorts
catch me on twitter where dudes is
catching the smoke um
uh uh
yo you guys are so fantastic on twitter
and y'all happening to be keeping it
really respectful yeah um also go to
lords of gaming.net where this week uh
cognito took my spot um and did some
destiny talk so i'm not really liking
the way he muscles me out of the
position
he's gonna oh he's gonna have to work
again this week on thursday because this
week on thursday i'm gonna be on behind
the sticks uh with my man so kyle got to
do double duty this week again with the
live
[Music]
man i'm not happy oh no it wasn't my
fault it was my fault yeah
yeah cause i couldn't do that day cause
he wanted to do wednesday i'm not
playing i'm not doing no longer
definitely launch he hit me he like are
you cool
you know what and i was like nah that's
my dude i'm not gonna sit there and bold
guard and block the situation let him go
i appreciate it but he's working this
week too yeah
how about it anyway look man again
salute everybody that pulled up switched
to the chat y'all laid shout out to one
bad mother she said great entertaining
show y'all make sundays better only
thing better than playing elder ring is
playing elder ring while listening to
iop wow absolutely much love man the
chat was fantastic again go support
demeo that's one of the hottest games
out right now more people play it it's
on vr the steam edition is right now
free downloaded demo all that good stuff
i'll put the link one more time i'm i'm
riding for the game the game is high
quality they don't realize what they do
realize but it's a hit it's a hit this
thing they know what it is
yeah it's going to be crazy go support
that check it out and then hopefully we
get some console versions so i'm that's
why i got to be pushing for this
hopefully i get a playstation vr free
yeah
hey xbox if you're listening man you
know what i'm saying kyle's pc version
you know it is what it is
i've done my promotion tip yo everybody
enjoy today's sunday we're going to
leave you with the trailer that we
played earlier for demo with ghost gust
offs denmark and the entire resolution
games again oh send some love to solve
so i was working send him some love we
missed yourself he ain't sick of nothing
he said he ain't sick he had worried he
just had to work but we missed the super
chat anyway everybody enjoy your sunday
we out peace
descending into the dark dungeons of
forgotten memories
[Music]
the mighty guardian found himself called
an old but familiar magic
whispering a call to adventure
compelled by fate he summoned the old
fellowship
all right boys what's the plan of attack
here you gotta get the key and then we
gotta go to the exit
all right i'm gonna try to take out this
little spider looking thing do it john
take him out
[Music]
okay hang on i got this
[Music]
what about this door over here i have a
feeling this could get ugly
they are killing you man we're taking a
beating
[Music]
we got these
[Music]
let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
you